I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Angela Kinsey. Hi, Jenna Fisher. We are on season three of The Office. Can you believe it? Can you believe we've broken down two full seasons and here we are about to start breaking down season three? I can't believe it. I feel like maybe it's because we're having such
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能讲给你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。安吉拉·金西。嗨，珍娜·菲舍尔。我们正在制作《办公室》第三季。你能相信吗？你能相信我们已经剖析完整整两季，而现在我们要开始剖析第三季了吗？我简直不敢相信。我觉得也许是因为我们过得太开心了，
a good time that it just went by so fast. This is season three, episode one, Gay Witch Hunt. This is a pretty big episode because we had some very juicy season two cliffhangers. This episode was written by Greg Daniels and directed by Ken Kwapis. And this is kind of significant because Ken Kwapis directed the season finale, Casino Night. So it was really great that we had the same director directing all those cliffhangers and then directing all of the answers here in our season three opener, I think. Yeah, I think that's really important, you guys, because, you know, Ken so knew the world and we felt so protected by him as actors.
所以时间才过得这么快。这是第三季第一集，《同志搜捕令》。这集非常重要，因为我们在第二季留下了非常精彩的悬念。这一集由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，肯·夸皮斯执导。这很有意义，因为肯·夸皮斯执导了第三季季终集《赌场之夜》。所以，由同一个导演来执导所有这些悬念，然后又在这里导演我们第三季开播集的所有解答，真的太棒了。是的，我觉得这真的很重要，大家，因为，你知道的，肯非常了解这个世界，作为演员，我们觉得被他保护得很好。
And I felt like you and John really had to put yourself out there. So then I think it's great that Ken was there with you to sort of get you to the other side of that story. Yeah, there were certain directors that always made me feel particularly safe and protected and free to play around. And that one of those was Ken, for sure. Yeah. All right. I have a summary for this episode. Here we go. Gay witch hunt. Michael, you didn't ask me if I wanted a summary. I didn't. You told me to point it out. You gave me such grief in that other podcast about asking if I
而且我觉得你和约翰真的付出了很多。所以我认为肯能在那里陪着你们，带你们走到那个故事的另一面，这真的很棒。是的，有些导演总是让我感到特别安全、受到保护，并且可以自由发挥。肯绝对就是其中之一。是的。好吧。我为这一集准备了一个摘要。我们开始吧。同志搜捕令。迈克尔，你刚才没问我想要听摘要吗？我没问。你让我提出来的。你在另一个播客里为我问是否
should give a summary or asking if I should give fast facts. And I got all my head about it. So now I'm just doing it. I'm just plowing forward. Okay. As your BFF now, it just tickles me and delights me when you say, Angela, would you like to hear a summary? All right. Angela, would you like to hear a summary? I really would. Well, in Gay Witch Hunt, Michael gets in trouble for using homosexual slurs at work. This results in an HR nightmare. Toby has to deal with him, and Oscar is reluctantly forced out of the closet. Meanwhile, we watch Jim adjust to his new life and new job in Stanford. That was a fantastic summary. All right, let's, Angela, can I do fast facts?
应该给出一个摘要或者是否应该给出快速事实而抱怨了一通。这让我脑子里很乱。所以我现在直接做了。我直接切入正题了。好吧。作为你现在的闺蜜，你问“安吉拉，你想听个摘要吗？”，这真的让我感到很高兴也很开心。好吧。安吉拉，你想听个摘要吗？我真的很想听。好吧，在《同志搜捕令》中，迈克尔因为在工作中使用同性恋污蔑性词汇而惹上麻烦。这导致了一场人力资源噩梦。托比不得不处理这件事，而奥斯卡则被迫出柜。与此同时，我们看着吉姆适应他在斯坦福的新生活和新工作。那真是个绝妙的摘要。好了，安吉拉，我能讲快速事实吗？
Yeah. Oh, yay. Okay, fast fact number one, we've got two big new characters on the show. We have Andy Bernard played by Ed Helms and Karen Filippelli played by Rashida Jones. Yes, this is a big deal. You guys big deal. They're going to be with us for a while, as you know, fans of the show. And we were really excited. Oh, this was so cool. So I had a chance to talk to Ed Helms. Yeah. And I love him. I know. We got on the phone and we chitty chatted about his debut on The Office and he told me a bunch of really cool stuff. And I texted with Rashida. So I've got some really great Karen behind the scenes stuff to share with you guys. I love it. All right. So here's what Ed told me.
太好了。噢，耶。好的，快速事实一，剧里有两位非常重要的新角色。我们有由埃德·赫尔姆斯扮演的安迪·伯纳德，以及由拉什达·琼斯扮演的凯伦·菲利佩利。是的，这可是件大事。大家，这绝对是大事。正如剧迷们所知，他们会陪伴我们一段时间。我们真的很兴奋。噢，这太酷了。所以我有机会和埃德·赫尔姆斯聊了聊。是的。我太喜欢他了。我懂。我们通了电话，闲聊了他在《办公室》中的首次亮相，他告诉我很多非常酷的事情。我还和拉什达发了短信。所以我有一些关于凯伦的超棒幕后故事要分享给大家。我太喜欢了。好吧。埃德是这么跟我说的。
Ed told me that he was a huge fan of the original BBC office. And he said not very many people know this. He originally auditioned in New York for the role of Jim. Oh, I didn't know that. I mean, it makes sense, right? It makes sense that he was sort of of that group of actors at the time, but I didn't know that. He said he didn't get the role, obviously, but he heard that Steve got the lead role of Michael Scott, and he was so excited because he had worked with Steve on The Daily Show. Yes. So they were kind of friends. They knew one another. He said this made him so excited
埃德告诉我，他是原版BBC《办公室》的超级粉丝。他说没多少人知道这件事。他最初在纽约试镜吉姆这个角色。噢，我不知道。我的意思是，这说得通，对吧？他当时确实属于那一批演员，但我不知道这事。他说他显然没得到这个角色，但他听说史蒂夫得到了迈克尔·斯科特这个主角，他超级兴奋，因为他曾在《每日秀》上和史蒂夫合作过。是的。所以他们算是朋友。他们彼此认识。他说这让他
for our American version of the show. And he watched it and he loved it. And then somewhere near the end of season two, he got a phone call to meet with Greg Daniels and Paul Lieberstein about a new character that they wanted to introduce in season three. He said the meeting went great. He absolutely loved the character of Andy.
对我们美国版的剧集感到无比兴奋。他观看了并且非常喜欢。然后在第二季快结束时，他接到一个电话，去见格雷格·丹尼尔斯和保罗·利伯斯坦，谈谈他们想在第三季引入的一个新角色。他说会面进行得非常顺利。他非常喜欢安迪这个角色。
He also told me that he was originally only asked to do a total of eight episodes on the show because they thought that the Stanford storyline would not necessarily end in a merger and that his character would be finished after Jim returned back to Dunder Mifflin. That was the plan, that Jim would eventually return. But this idea that the other Stanford characters would return wasn't quite in the works yet. But he also told me that they weren't totally sure about leaving Jim separated
他还告诉我，他们最初只邀请他总共出演八集，因为他们认为斯坦福的故事线不一定会以合并告终，而且他的角色在吉姆回到邓德米夫林后就会结束。原本的计划是吉姆最终会回归。但其他斯坦福角色也会回归的想法当时还没有完全提上日程。不过他也告诉我，他们对于让吉姆分开
for so long. So they would only hire him in two episode chunks. Oh, my gosh. Yeah. So they said, like, OK, we're going to probably keep you for eight, but we'll only hire you for two episodes at a time. And he was living in New York at the time. Yeah. So he came out to L.A. He said he stayed at the Sportsman's Lodge in North Hollywood. You know, the Sportsman's Lodge. I do. I do know the Sportsman's Lodge. I mean, how would you describe the Sportsman's Lodge? I would describe the Sportsman's Lodge as sort of like a retro, could maybe be cool motel. It reminds me of the place where they stay in the movie Vacation when Christie Brinkley jumps in the swimming pool with Chris Wald. Good talk, Russ.
这么久并不是完全有把握。所以他们只按两集的合同来雇他。噢，天哪。是的，所以他们会说，好吧，我们可能会留你八集，但我们一次只跟你签两集的合同。他当时住在纽约。是的。所以他来到了洛杉矶。他说他住在北好莱坞的运动员 lodge。你知道运动员 lodge 吗？我认识。我确实知道运动员 lodge。我的意思是，你会怎么形容运动员 lodge？我会把运动员 lodge 形容为有点像复古的、也许还挺酷的汽车旅馆。它让我想起电影《假期历险记》里克里斯·布林克利和克里斯·沃尔德一起跳进游泳池的那家他们住的酒店。聊得不错，罗斯。
Good talk. It's a famous old hotel in California. It does have some folklore, though, because like when I got here, I drove past it and I was with like a friend I met in like an acting class. And they're like, you know, every day when John Wayne was done on the set, he would go to the bar at Sportsman's Lodge and have a whiskey. I was like, no way. Well, it was originally built so that people could hunt like ducks and stuff. Like there was a whole pond that was part of the sportsman's lodge and they had a diner, a breakfast diner. And Angela, there are pictures of John Wayne all over this diner.
聊得不错。这是加州一家著名的老酒店。它确实有一些民间传说，因为当我来到这里时，我开车路过它，当时我和一个在表演课上认识的朋友在一起。他们说，你知道吗，约翰·韦恩每天在片场拍完戏后，都会去运动员 lodge 的酒吧喝一杯威士忌。我说，不会吧。嗯，它最初建的时候是为了让人类去打猎之类的，比如鸭子。运动员 lodge 还有一个完整的池塘，他们还有一家餐厅，一家早餐店。而且，安吉拉，这家餐厅到处都是约翰·韦恩的照片。
Didn't we once meet there and have breakfast together? I'm sure we did. Anyway, so that's where Ed was living. That's where Ed was living. He said he rented a convertible, a Sebring. He's pretty sure he basically rented Michael Scott's car because he was like, I'm in California. I'm going to rent a convertible. I just found that so charming. But he said that by about the sixth episode, they came and offered him a deal to stay for the whole rest of the season. And he was really excited and he moved to California. I love that.
我们是不是曾经在那里见面并一起吃过早餐？我确信我们去过。不管怎样，这就是埃德当时住的地方。这就是埃德当时住的地方。他说他租了一辆敞篷车，一辆赛百灵。他确信自己基本上租了迈克尔·斯科特的车，因为他当时想：“我在加州。我要租一辆敞篷车。”我只觉得这太迷人了。但他说，大概到了第六集时，他们来找他，提供了一份让他演完整整剩下几季的合约。他非常激动，于是搬到了加州。我太喜欢了。
And then, Angela, I have a few little more things to share about Ed, but I will sprinkle that into the episode. You sprinkle those in. I'm going to sprinkle in my Rashida tidbits. I will say that I love Rashida. Jenna, we were so excited to have her on set. We would hang out in your trailer. Like when the guys were playing their Madden football or on set. We would hang out in your trailer,
然后，安吉拉，我还有一些关于埃德的小事情要分享，但我会把它们穿插到这一集中。你把那些穿插进来吧。我要穿插我的拉什达小花絮。我要说的是，我太喜欢拉什达了。珍娜，我们非常高兴她能加入剧组。我们会待在你的房车里。就像当男士们在玩美式橄榄球或者在片场时。我们会待在你的房车里，
like when the guys were playing their Madden football or whatever, we would all hang out in your trailer. And she's just like such an amazing, genuine, smart, like woman. I just adore her. Oh, Angela, I feel like we had a huge girl crush on her. We did. We a little bit followed her around because I remember at first we didn't have any scenes with her and we didn't even see her, but we would see her at the table reads. And then we, I have a picture of us holding our scripts, the three of us and taking our lunch to my trailer. And that's what we did for the first six weeks.
就像当男士们在玩美式橄榄球或者别的什么时，我们都会待在你的房车里。她真的是那种超级棒、真诚、聪明的女性。我简直爱死她了。噢，安吉拉，我觉得我们当时超级崇拜她。我们确实是。我们有点像尾随着她，因为我记得一开始我们和她没有任何对手戏，甚至看不到她，但我们在剧本围读时会看到她。然后我们，我有一张我们拿着剧本的照片，我们三个，然后把午餐拿到我的房车里。这就是我们前六周一直在做的事情。
We would just see her at the table read, but then we would bring her to my trailer and we would just pepper her at the table read but then we would bring her to my trailer and we would just pepper her with questions because she is like gosh she is such a force right she's just cool she's really cool and nice and you and i you and i let's face it we were kind of dorks growing up and so we got to hang out with like someone really cool. She upped our game for sure. She upped our game. Let's move on to fast fact number two. We filmed this episode in late July and over the summer break in early July, we were nominated for an Emmy Award for Best Comedy Series for season two of The Office. Yes. This was such a whirlwind time.
我们只在剧本围读时看到她，但接着我们会把她带到我的房车里，我们只是在剧本围读时但接着我们会把她带到我的房车里，我们只是向她抛出一连串的问题，因为她真的是，天哪，她太有气场了，对吧？她就是很酷。她真的既酷又好，而且你和我，你和我，让我们面对现实吧，我们成长过程中都有点书呆子气，所以我们能和真正很酷的人一起玩。她绝对提升了我们的水平。她提升了我们的水平。让我们进入第二个快速事实。我们在七月下旬拍摄了这一集，而在七月初的暑假期间，我们因《办公室》第二季获得了艾美奖最佳喜剧类剧集的提名。是的。这真是一段旋风般的时光。
We were suddenly like on the map and nominated for this award. And it was crazy. Remember how surreal that was? Yeah. Yeah. Well, do you also remember that while we were shooting this episode, we also had to film a promo for the Emmy Awards. They were being hosted by Conan O'Brien. And he came to our set one day. Do you remember that? I do. And you know, Conan and Greg were good friends. So we were, you know, excited to have him there. And I have a photo. I don't know why it's in black and white. But I sort of went through this phase where I would buy black and white film for my camera, old school camera guys, where you had to buy film. And I have a black and white photo of us all standing around Conan on our set. Well, I looked up this Emmy promo on YouTube and it's there. If you guys want to look at it, it's actually really funny. So also at this time, the TV show Lost was a really big deal. And so the beginning of this promo is Conan on an airplane that crashes into the water.
我们突然之间就声名大噪，并获得了这个奖项的提名。这太疯狂了。还记得当时那种超现实的感觉吗？是的。是的。嗯，你还记得吗，在我们拍摄这一集的同时，我们还不得不为艾美奖拍摄一个宣传片。颁奖典礼由柯南·奥布莱恩主持。有一天他来到了我们的片场。你还记得吗？我记得。你知道的，柯南和格雷格是好朋友。所以我们，你知道的，很高兴他能来。我有一张照片。我不知道为什么它是黑白的。但我当时经历过这样一个阶段，我会为我的相机买黑白胶卷，老派相机的粉丝们，当时你得买胶卷。我有一张我们所有人围着柯南站在片场的黑白照片。嗯，我在 YouTube 上查了这个艾美奖宣传片，它就在那里。如果你们想看的话，其实真的挺搞笑的。另外在这个时期，电视剧《迷失》非常火爆。所以这个宣传片的开头是柯南坐在一架坠入水中的飞机上。
And then he gets out onto a beach and he runs into cast members from Lost. And he's like, I'm hosting the Emmys. I have to get to the Emmys. And then he goes over to the hatch and he opens up the hatch and he gets in. But when he comes out of the hatch, he comes out of our ceiling, right down onto the desks in the office. And then we have this whole scene. And I had this really cool moment where he and I trade looks the way Jim and Pam trade looks. And then he does a talking head about the receptionist and how he wishes he could stay, but he's got to get to the Emmys. Oh my gosh. It like, it was so cool. It was so cool. I love it. But it's really funny because then he just keeps going through like all the sets of all
然后他爬上一个海滩，遇到了《迷失》的演员们。他说：“我是艾美奖主持人。我得去参加艾美奖。”接着他走向舱口，打开舱口钻了进去。但当他从舱口出来时，他从我们的天花板钻了出来，直接落在了办公室的办公桌上。然后我们有了整整一幕。我有一个非常酷的时刻，他和我和吉姆与帕姆交换眼神的方式一样交换了眼神。然后他做了一个关于前台接待员的面对镜头独白，谈到他多么希望能留下来，但他必须去参加艾美奖。噢，天哪。这简直，太酷了。太酷了。我太喜欢了。但这真的很有趣，因为随后他接着走遍了所有
the different shows that were nominated that year. And that was like a that felt big to be part of some Emmy montage and to be nominated. I just remember there was a big buzz all across the set when we came back to work from the summer. All right, Jenna, hit me with a fastback. Number three. All right. Fastback number three. All right, fast fact number three. So in this episode, you guys know it opens with Jim no longer working in
那一年获得提姆的剧集的片场。成为艾美奖蒙太奇的一部分并获得提名感觉意义重大。我只记得当我们从暑假回到工作岗位时，整个片场都弥漫着热烈的讨论。好吧，珍娜，告诉我第三个快速事实。第三个。好的，快速事实三。那么在这集里，大家知道它开场时吉姆已经不再在
Scranton. He still works for Dunder Mifflin, but he's working at the Stanford branch now in Connecticut. We got a lot of questions about the Stanford branch. Where were the Stanford branch scenes actually filmed? And then can you describe how things were filmed with these two different offices and the fact that John wasn't working with you guys for a bunch of episodes? Did he film in the same location? Did he miss you guys?
斯克兰顿工作了。他仍然为邓德米夫林工作，但现在他在康涅狄格州的斯坦福分公司工作。我们收到了很多关于斯坦福分公司的问题。斯坦福分公司的场景实际上是在哪里拍摄的？然后你们能描述一下这两个不同的办公室是怎么拍摄的吗？还有约翰在好几集里没有和你们一起工作这件事？他是在同一个地点拍摄的吗？他想念你们吗？
Did you miss him? Give us all the details, please. Thank you. That's a good question. Yes. Well, I'll say the Stanford branch was over on our warehouse set. It was just in that other building. We had two big sound stages and one sound stage was completely dedicated to the Scranton branch.
你们想念他吗？请给我们所有的细节。谢谢。这真是个好问题。是的，我会说斯坦福分公司其实就在我们的仓库片场。它就在那栋别的建筑里。我们有两个巨大的声音舞台，其中一个声音舞台完全专门用于斯克兰顿分公司。
And the other sound stage was our warehouse set and also what we called our swing set. So anytime we had to build, for example, the New York offices, they had a section of the warehouse that they could put up the New York offices and then they would take them down. And then like when Pam goes to the hospital and has her baby or when Angela and Oscar move in together, that's where they put Oscar's apartment. That's where they put the hospital. Right. It was the little swing set area. And so that's where Stanford was built. And I remember when they built the Stanford set, I remember us being like, holy crap,
而另一个声音舞台则是我们的仓库片场，也就是我们所谓的活动布景。所以任何时候我们需要搭建，比如说纽约办公室，他们可以在仓库里划出一部分搭建纽约办公室，然后拍完就拆掉。再比如当帕姆去医院生孩子，或者当安吉拉和奥斯卡搬到一起住时，那就是他们放置奥斯卡公寓的地方。那就是他们放置医院的地方。没错，那就是那个小活动布景区域。斯坦福就是建在那里的。我记得当他们搭建斯坦福布景时，我记得我们当时的反应是：“天呐，
look how fancy it is. It looked more modern, a little bit more sleek. I was like, is Dunder Mifflin like the old branch? Like Stanford looks a little fancy, fancy Stanford. I know. I looked at, you know, I love to look at the backdrops that are out our fake windows. Yeah. Jim talks about the view in Stanford and it's great. Like they're clearly up in like this big high rise building. Yeah. It's really quite nice out that window. And all their desks are new and the desk chairs
看看它有多高级。”它看起来更现代，线条更流畅一点。我当时想：“邓德米夫林算什么旧分公司吗？斯坦福看起来真高级，高档的斯坦福。”我懂。我看了，你知道我喜欢看假窗户后面的背景。是的。吉姆谈到了斯坦福的风景，真的很棒。就像他们显然在那种大型高层建筑里一样。是的，透过窗户看出去真的很不错。而且他们所有的办公桌都是新的，办公桌椅子
are new and the lamps. It's like Stanford's nicer. Well, I did trade some emails with Kent Zabornak, Kentopedia. And he said that when we got this order for season three, we got a little more money in our budget. Oh, did we? Yes. And Aaron Carrington Smith wrote in to say, it really seems like starting in season three, the show branches out. We go to Stanford, but you guys also film a lot more outside of the actual office. Was that a conscious decision? Kent told me we were able to do that because we got this bump in our budget. We're going to see a lot more episodes where we go on location and they were
也是新的，还有台灯。就好像斯坦福更好一点。嗯，我确实和肯·扎博纳克（Kentopedia）交换了一些电子邮件。他说，当我们拿到第三季的订单时，我们的预算多了一点。噢，是吗？是的。而亚伦·卡灵顿·史密斯写信来说，看起来从第三季开始，这部剧的业务范围真的扩大了。我们去了斯坦福，但你们也在实际办公室之外拍摄了更多内容。这是一个有意识的决定吗？肯告诉我，我们能做到这一点是因为我们的预算增加了。我们将看到更多我们实地拍摄的剧集，而且他们
able to build a really nice Stanford branch all because we had a little bit more money to work with now that we were Emmy nominated and all. Emmy nominated and had a big movie star on set. That's right. We got a little bit more coin, guys, so we could travel. And then as far as John, I remember it was super weird that we didn't have him with us for like six or eight weeks. Yeah, it was super weird that we didn't have him with us for like six or eight weeks. Yeah, it was weird. And I remember like if we would run into him for whatever reason,
能够搭建一个非常不错的斯坦福分公司，这全是因为我们现在有了更多的资金可以运作，既然我们获得了艾美奖提名等等。获得了艾美奖提名，片场还有了一位大电影明星。没错，大家，我们多了一点资金，所以我们可以去旅行了。至于约翰，我记得我们有六八周的时间没有和他在一块儿，这超级奇怪。是的，我们有六八周的时间没有和他在一块儿，这超级奇怪。是的，这很诡异。我记得如果我们出于某种原因偶遇他，
maybe he came for a wardrobe fitting and we were at lunch or something. We'd be like, what's it like over there? How is everybody? Is everyone nice? Like, what's it like? Like as if he truly had moved away. I remember that too. And he was so super gushy about Ed and Rashida
也许他来试装，而我们正在吃午饭什么的。我们就会问：“那边怎么样？大家怎么样？大家都好吗？就像是，那是什么感觉？”就好像他真的搬走了。我也记得那件事。而且他对埃德和拉什达赞不绝口，
and working over on the Stanford set. He was, he seemed like he was having the best time. And again, I think I had a little FOMO. I was like, well, what's happening over in Stanford? Yeah. Why is it so great over there? And then when we had table reads and they were all there, they had like inside jokes. And I'm like, what the heck? What's that inside joke? Dang it. Exactly. Big brother, kid, sister. Yeah. Don't do that with anyone else, buddy. I totally remember all of that. And so they would shoot the Stanford branch like one or two days a week and we would have off and then we would shoot over in the Scranton side for the rest of the week. And we really did not see each other except for those table reads or those little run ins.
还有在斯坦福片场工作。他当时看起来过得开心极了。再说一次，我觉得我有一点 FOMO（错失恐惧症）。我当时想，好吧，斯坦福那边到底在发生什么？是的。为什么那边那么棒？然后当我们进行剧本围读时，他们都在那儿，他们有各种内部笑话。我就想：“搞什么鬼？那个内部笑话是什么？”可恶。没错。大哥哥，小妹妹。是的。别跟其他人那样做，伙计。我完全记得所有这些。所以他们每周会拍一两天斯坦福分公司，而我们放假，然后一周剩下的时间我们在斯克兰顿那边拍摄。除了剧本围读或那些短暂的偶遇之外，我们真的不怎么能见到彼此。
Yeah, so crazy. It was crazy. But it built the tension. I think it was good, especially for Jim and Pam, because, you know, you guys, I think, then brought that time apart back on screen together. Does that make sense? part back on screen together. Does that make sense? Oh, Angela, I completely used all of my feelings with John being over on that other set to the character of Pam, because you really became closest with the people who you had the most scenes with because you had to spend so much downtime with them. And for those whole first two years of the show, I was paired with John so often.
是的，太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。但它营造了紧张感。我觉得这挺好的，特别是对吉姆和帕姆来说，因为，你知道的，你们大家，我觉得，随后把那段分开的时间又带回了荧幕上。这说得通吗？把那段时间又带回了荧幕上。这说得通吗？噢，安吉拉，我把和约翰在那个不同片场的所有情绪都完全倾注到了帕姆这个角色身上，因为你确实会和那些拍最多对手戏的人最亲近，因为你必须花大量的时间和他们待在一起。而在该剧的前整整两年里，我和约翰搭档得太频繁了。
this whole first two years of the show, I was paired with John so often. He really was my buddy, you know? And I spent a lot of time with him. And now he was just gone. And again, I can't stress it enough. This was before smartphones. So it wasn't like after this summer break,
在前整整两年里，我和约翰搭档得太频繁了。他真的是我的死党，你知道吗？我花了很多时间和他在一块儿。而现在他突然就走了。再说一次，怎么强调都不为过。这是在智能手机出现之前。所以不是说在这个暑假之后，
we had been tech, we weren't texting. You didn't text anyone, you guys. There was no texting. You weren't like really in touch touch and so here we were back from summer break but i didn't have my work buddy he was like off on some other set and so i did have like all that like fomo and all that like what's up what's up over there yeah what's up over there so when they came back i just used it for my character well those are good fast facts lady those are real good i'm excited to get into this episode because i feel like we both have some behind the scenes stuff i know you're holding out on me lady i know you probably
我们一直在联系，我们当时可没在发短信。你们不会给任何人发短信的，大家。那时没有短信功能。你们并没有真正保持密切联系，所以我们从暑假回来后，我却失去了我的工作搭档。他就像去了别的片场一样，所以我确实有了那种 FOMO，还有那种“那边到底怎么回事，那边到底怎么回事”的感觉。是的，那边怎么回事。所以当他们回来时，我把这些情绪全都用到了我的角色身上。好吧，这些都是很好的快速事实，辣妈。这些真的很好。我很兴奋能开始这一集，因为我觉得我们俩都有一些幕后料。我知道你对我有保留，辣妈。我知道你可能
have some kentopedia and i have some stuff too i talked to some folks so should we take a break and then dive in let's take a break and then dive in? Let's take a break and then we'll dive into Gay Witch Hunt. Okay, we are back. It starts off with Dwight being so pleasant, trimming his fingernails at work. Why, Dwight? Why? We reveal, guess who's sitting next to him? Not Jim.
有些“肯百科”的料，而我也有一些料。我和一些伙伴聊过，所以我们应该休息一下然后再深入探讨吗？让我们休息一下，然后再深入探讨。让我们休息一下，然后我们来深入探讨《同志搜捕令》。好吧，我们回来了。开场是德怀特表现得如此随和，在工作时修剪指甲。为什么，德怀特？为什么？我们揭晓了，猜猜谁坐在他旁边？不是吉姆。
And no longer the temp. It's Ryan. And can we talk about that Ryan got a whole new look? A bunch of people look a little different. A little better. He like cut his hair short and it's not floppy anymore. And it looks like there's some gel. Anyway, this is the new improved Ryan.
也不再是临时工了。是瑞安。我们能聊聊瑞安换了全新造型这件事吗？很多人看起来都有点不一样。稍微变好了一点。他把头发剪短了，不再那么杂乱了。看起来好像还抹了发胶。不管怎样，这就是全新升级的瑞安。
He's no longer the temp and he's got a whole new look. Well, then we move to Pam typing at her desk and she looks longingly over at Jim's old desk at Ryan. And this is when we flash back to casino night. Oh, my God. And we get an extension of the scene. We see that a whole thing happened after the kiss. Yes. They both admit to each other that they've wanted to do that for a long time. And Pam is like, I think we're drunk. And Jim's like, I'm not drunk. Are you drunk?
他不再是临时工了，而且有了全新的造型。然后，镜头转到帕姆在办公桌前打字，她渴望地看着吉姆以前的空桌子，看着瑞安。这就是我们闪回到《赌场之夜》的时候。噢，天哪。我们看到了那场戏的延伸。我们看到亲吻之后发生了一整件事情。是的。他们都向对方承认，他们想这么做已经很久了。帕姆说：“我想我们喝醉了。”吉姆说：“我没醉。你醉了吗？”
And she's like, no, no, I'm not drunk. And then Jim goes in for another kiss. Yeah. And she's like, I can't. And he's like, you're going to marry him. And you're like, yes. Oh, I know. We had a lot of fan questions about this. Jenna Adams, Matt Grasso, Brett Hedges, Alyssa Dunn and many others wanted to know, did we film the continuation of the kiss scene at the same time as Casino Night? the continuation of the kiss scene at the same time as Casino Night?
她回答：“没，没，我没醉。”然后吉姆凑过去又亲了一下。是的。她说：“我不能。”吉姆说：“你要嫁给他了。”而你说：“是的。”噢，我知道。我们收到了很多关于这一集的粉丝提问。珍娜·亚当斯、马特·格拉索、布雷特·赫奇斯、阿丽莎·邓恩以及许多其他人想知道，我们是在拍摄《赌场之夜》的同时拍摄了吻戏的续集吗？
Or did we have to recreate the moment for Gay Witch Hunt? Guys, we had to recreate it. We had to recreate it. And this is like, thank God for Ken Kwapis. Thank God we had the same director. So we had to redo everything. Kim Ferry had taken photos of every side of my head head and she painstakingly redid my hairdo. Thank God my dress still fit. We added a new camera angle. I don't know if you noticed that. They set up the spy shot from the kitchen and then they put an extra camera inside
还是我们不得不为《同志搜捕令》重新演绎这个时刻？大家，我们必须重新演绎。我们必须重新演绎。谢天谢地，多亏了肯·夸皮斯。感谢上帝，我们有同一个导演。所以我们必须重拍一切。金·费瑞拍下了我脑袋每个角度的照片，并且煞费苦心地帮我重新做好了发型。谢天谢地，我的裙子还穿得下。我们加了一个新的摄像机角度。我不知道你们有没有注意到。他们从厨房设置了偷拍镜头，然后在
the conference room shooting through the blinds so that you could finally now see Pam's face and Pam's reaction. I don't know if this is true, Jenna. And I don't know if it's just because I had this information in my brain that I knew you had to recreate this moment. This is ridiculous, but I do feel like you're at a different position on Jim's desk. I feel like you're a little further down. I feel like you're not right by the phone, which is where you were because you had hung up the phone. Right? So this is just a little catch. No, Angela, your catch is good. I think in order to get that camera angle through the blinds in the conference room, we had to scoochie scooch just a few inches down the desk.
会议室里面放了一个额外的摄像机，透过百叶窗拍摄，这样你们终于可以看到帕姆的脸和帕姆的反应了。我不知道这是不是真的，珍娜。我不知道这只是因为我的脑子里有这个信息，所以我知道你们必须重新演绎这一时刻。这太荒谬了，但我确实觉得你坐在吉姆办公桌上的位置变了。我觉得你往下坐了一点。我觉得你离电话不远了，而那是你之前的位置，因为你当时刚挂了电话。对吧？所以这只是一个小破绽。不，安吉拉，你发现得很准。我想为了让摄像机角度能够透过会议室的百叶窗拍到，我们不得不把屁股往下挪了那么几英寸。
Wow. Wow. I'm impressed that you caught that. I mean, we tried to we we tried our best to fool people but we had to re-kiss again because you'll notice that and that was like by the way they brought out like a still frame image to me and john of us kissing and they were like okay so now jenna your arm is here your hand is here john this is how you had your hand around her so we had to like painstakingly recreate the pose and everything so that it would look seamless but
哇。哇。我佩服你能发现这一点。我的意思是，我们试着，我们尽了最大努力去忽悠大家，但我们必须重新接吻，因为你会注意到，而且那次就像是，顺便说一句，他们拿出了我和约翰接吻的剧照给我看，他们说：“好吧，现在珍娜，你的手臂在这里，你的手在这里，约翰，这就是你搂着她腰的方式。”所以我们不得不煞费苦心地重现那个姿势和一切，这样看起来才能天衣无缝，但
if you watch we kiss and we pull away and start talking immediately so that was it was all recreation how awkward just think about this here's job. You go to work one day and someone's like, here's your job today. You need to find a photo of Jenna and John kissing as Jim and Pam. You need to print it out. I need multiple copies. A lot of people are going to be studying this photo. Then we're going to take it to Jenna and John. We're going to recreate the moment. I want it high res. I want it in color. Print me a bunch of photos of them kissing. Okay, thanks. Yeah, that was pretty much it, Ange. That was pretty much it. That was someone's job. That's so crazy. All right. Well, I love that little
如果你仔细看，我们亲完然后分开，立刻就开始说话了，所以这一切都是重新演绎的。多尴尬啊。想想看，约翰。你有一天去上班，然后有人说：“这是你今天的工作。你需要找到一张珍娜和约翰作为吉姆和帕姆接吻的照片。你需要把它打印出来。我需要多份复印件。很多人会研究这张照片。然后我们要把它拿给珍娜和约翰。我们要重现那个时刻。我要高分辨率的。我要彩色的。给我打印一堆他们接吻的照片。好的，谢谢。”是的，差不多就是这样，安姬。差不多就是这样。那是某人的工作。这太疯狂了。好吧。嗯，我很喜欢那个幕后小
behind the scenes moment, Jenna. I love that you acknowledge that you weren't kissing by the phone where you hung up with your mom. I love it. But I want to get into the episode a little bit here. Now, Toby is in Michael's office. We're at two minutes, 13 seconds. He's talking to Toby because apparently Michael was inappropriate again. You know, he basically gives Oscar a hard time for liking Shakespeare in Love instead of Die Hard. Yeah. And maybe doesn't word it very well. You guys doesn't word it the best. But when you watch this scene, watch Steve's performance as Michael realizes that Oscar is actually gay. Yes. His transformation of going from like, yeah, yeah,
花絮，珍娜。我很高兴你承认你们接吻时并没有靠近挂了妈妈电话的那个电话。我太喜欢了。但我想在这集里深入讨论一下。现在，托比在迈克尔的办公室里。时间是两分十三秒。他在跟迈克尔谈话，因为显然迈克尔又做出不恰当的举动了。你知道的，他 basicamente 难为奥斯卡，因为奥斯卡喜欢《莎翁情史》而不是《虎胆龙威》。是的。而且可能话没说好。大家，他话说得实在不怎么样。但当你观看这一幕时，看史蒂夫作为迈克尔意识到奥斯卡其实是同性恋时的表演。是的。他从“是啊，是啊，
whatever. Yeah, no, I know. And then it's such a great acting moment, in my opinion. Steve, once again, just blew me away. And here's my other thing I need to point out in this scene, you guys, and I don't know, maybe it's controversial, but you know who I think outed Oscar? Toby! Toby! Yes! This is going to come up later, Angela, because Jan is going to come into the office and reprimand Michael for outing Oscar to the rest of the office. And she goes on this whole speech where she's like, it is a big moment in a person's life and they should be able to choose how and when they come out to people. And the whole time I just kept thinking, Toby, Toby, Oscar, Oscar told that to Toby in confidence. Yes. And Toby told the one person who would not be able to contain that information. Here's two people Toby could have
无所谓”的表情转变……是的，不，我知道。在我看来，这真是一个极佳的表演时刻。史蒂夫再一次让我惊艳了。这是我在这场戏中需要指出的另一件事，大家，我不知道，也许这很有争议，但你们知道我认为是谁出柜了奥斯卡吗？托比！托比！是的！这待会儿还会谈到，安吉拉，因为简会来到办公室，斥责迈克尔向办公室其他人出柜了奥斯卡。她发表了一长串演讲，大意是：这是一个人生命中的重要时刻，他们应该能够选择如何以及何时向别人出柜。而整个过程我脑子里一直在想：托比，托比！奥斯卡，奥斯卡是私下把这件事告诉托比的。是的。而托比却把这件事告诉了那个最守不住秘密的人。这里有两个托比可以告诉的人，如果他想让每个人都知道的话：迈克尔和凯利。没错。就是这样。就是这样。所以现在，我的意思是，迈克尔决定他必须向奥斯卡道歉。当然，这不是私下进行的。他直接走到会计工位区。凯文和安吉拉交换了几个眼神。然后迈克尔说：“嗯，也许，你知道的，我们可以一起出去吃晚饭，你可以向我解释这是怎么运作的。”奥斯卡说：“好啊，那太棒了。是的，我们应该这么做。”噢，安吉拉。安吉拉，我有《同志搜捕令》的剧本。你知道奥斯卡是即兴发挥的吗？这太棒了。史蒂夫和奥斯卡即兴发挥了整段对话，剧本里根本没有。我当时想，是的。当史蒂夫——现在听着，我有时会说这是即兴发挥，
told if he wanted everyone to know Michael and Kelly. Correct. There you go. There you go. So now, I mean, Michael decides he's got to apologize to Oscar. Of course, it's not in private. He just walks over to the accounting desk pod. You have Kevin and Angela exchanging some glances. And then Michael's like, well, maybe, you know, we could go out to dinner and you could explain to me how it works. And Oscar's like, yeah, that would be wonderful. Yeah, we should do that. Oh, Angela. Angela, I have the script for Gay Witch Hunt. You know, Oscar did Oscar improvise. That would be be wonderful Steve and Oscar improvised that whole couplet that is not in the script this I wondered yeah when Steve now listen I say improvised sometimes
编剧当时在片场，他们会向演员抛出台词，但我知道在这一特定剧集中，史蒂夫和奥斯卡采取了很大的自由发挥，他们俩都是即兴表演大师。是的。而且他们在这些场景中做了很多即兴发挥。我相信史蒂夫即兴发挥了那句台词，大概是“也许我们可以去喝杯啤酒，你就可以告诉我你是怎么对其他男人做那种事的”。而奥斯卡则回应：“是的，迈克尔。听起来太棒了。这太棒了。”太棒了。
the writers were on set and they would pitch lines to the actors but I know that in this particular episode Steve and Oscar took a lot of liberties they are both masterful improvisers. Yes. And they improvised a lot on these scenes. And I believe that Steve improvised that line about maybe we could go have a beer and you could just tell me how you do that to other dudes. And that Oscar was like that. Yes, Michael. That sounds wonderful. That's wonderful. What a wonderful.
我等不及了。就好像他语气里的那种调调，但这两个人在这一集里的所有表现都完全让我开心极了。我太高兴了。他们太棒了，他们太棒了。而且，你知道的，接着我们有凯文和安吉拉，他们现在知道了，对吧？我们来了，我们来了。我们开始了，我们开跑了。现在，有两条随机的冷知识，好吗？在我的日记里，我写道我真的很喜欢我穿的那件毛衣，而且我问了服装部门他们是在哪里买的，他们是在 Urban Outfitters 买的。你自己私下买了一件吗？
I can't wait. It's like the tone in his voice but they everything about those two together in this episode completely delighted me i was so tickled they're so good they're so they're so good and you know then we have kevin and angela they're they're they know now right here we go here we go Here we go. We're off to the races. We're off to the races. And now, two random pieces of trivia, okay? In my journal, I wrote that I really like this sweater that I'm wearing, and that I asked the wardrobe department where they got it, and they got it at Urban Outfitters. Did you buy one for yourself in your personal life?
我没有。我想我当时在考虑，然后可能觉得太奇怪了。居然穿着我角色穿的那件毛衣到处走。不过，是的，那件毛衣来自 Urban Outfitters。所以看看这个。安吉拉·马丁。这算是一家挺时髦的店铺，不过也许我们预算比较多。是的。
I didn't. I think I was considering it, and then maybe thought it'd be too weird. But to walk around in the sweater my character wears. But yeah, so that sweater was from Urban Outfitters. So look at that. Angela Martin. That's kind of a hip store, but maybe we had a bigger budget. Yeah.
服装部不再去 NBC 拿那些旧衣服了，而是去 Urban Outfitters 给安吉拉·马丁买衣服。另一件事是，在三分五十八秒时，那张救助犬的复印照片不在我的隔板上了。在你的隔板上，它不在了，它没了。为了第三季被移除了，为了第三季被移除了。它没了。为了第三季被移除了。为了第三季被移除了。它没了。如果你是这个播客的常客，你知道我们一直在追踪安吉拉隔板上的这张狗的照片。是的，它没了。它没了。噢，大家都为此松了一口气。
Wardrobe stopped going to like the NBC and getting old the older clothes and went to urban outfitters for angela martin and then the other thing is at three minutes 58 seconds that whatever photocopy picture of the dog the rescue dog is no longer on my partition on your partition it's not there it's gone removed for season three removed for season. It's gone. Removed for season three. Removed for season three. It's gone. If you're a regular listener to this podcast, you know we've been tracking this picture of a dog on Angela's partition. Yeah, it's gone. It's gone. Oh, everyone's so relieved by that.
大家都对这个消息感到欣喜若狂。这将是今天这集最大的收获。是的，没错。这就是每个人都会谈论的焦点。今天这集的收获。是的，没错。这就是我要谈的。然后我只想指出，我觉得奥斯卡面对镜头的独白，一开始他否认自己是同性恋，然后他说：“你知道吗？是的，我是。好吧。”就像，我觉得他做得太棒了。我的意思是，他在这一整集中都表现得极好，但这只是一个非常小、非常快的独白，但我认为他真的在其中找到了一些层次感。
Everyone is so thrilled by that information. It's going to be the big takeaway from today's episode. Yeah, exactly. That's what everyone's going to talk about. takeaway from today's episode. Yeah, exactly. That's what I was going to talk about. And then I just want to point out, I thought Oscar's talking head where at first he's denying being gay. And then he just says, like, you know what? Yeah, I am. Okay. Like, I thought he did such a great job. I mean, he's fantastic in this whole episode, but it's just a really small, quick talking head. But I thought he just really found some layers to it.
我觉得这太完美了。嗯，你知道，剧本里奥斯卡还有另一个面对镜头的独白，我觉得真的非常非常有趣。没剪进去吗？没剪进去。他说：“当我申请邓德米夫林的工作时，我在面试中告诉迈克尔我是同性恋。”噢，我看到过这个。而他笑得停不下来。是的。他只是不停地笑，笑，笑。然后他雇用了我，并说：“太搞笑了。”这就是为什么我从未在办公室出柜的原因。我只是决定把这个秘密
And I thought it was perfect. Well, you know, there's another talking head that Oscar has in the script that I thought was really, really interesting. That didn't get in? It didn't get in. He says, when I applied for my job at Dunder Mifflin, I told Michael in my interview that I was gay. Oh, I saw this. And he couldn't stop laughing. Yes. He just kept laughing and laughing and laughing. And then he hired me and said, I'm hilarious. And that's why I've never come out at the office. I just decided to keep it
留给自己，在那之后。是的，没错。如果你们有 DVD 套装，那段在删减片段里，真的很好笑。我读剧本读到这里时觉得太搞笑了。噢，太好了。所以他们实际上拍了。太酷了。是的，它在删减片段里。好吧，大家，现在我们要去斯坦福了。吉姆正在他崭新的高级办公室里打电话。他向一位客户保证，虽然他不能说邓德米夫林纸的易燃性较低，但他承诺绝对不会比其他纸更容易燃烧。这就是他推销纸张的卖点。
to myself after that. Yes, that's right. If you guys have the DVD set that is in the deleted scenes, it's really funny. It was very funny when I was reading through the script and I came across that. Oh, good. So they actually filmed it. That's cool. Yeah, it's in the deleted scenes. Well, guys, now we're going to go over to Stanford. Jim is on the phone in his new fancy office. He is assuring a customer that while he cannot say that Dunder Mifflin paper is less flammable, he will promise that is definitely not more flammable than other paper. That's his sales pitch for the paper.
我们收到了来自凯瑟琳·兰格里奇的粉丝提问兼粉丝发现。在四分五十三秒。安吉拉，你注意到约翰的电脑上有一张便签，上面只写着“微笑”这个词吗？没有。上面写着“微笑”。她写信来说：“那是吉姆写给吉姆的便签，还是同事写给吉姆的便签？不管怎样，吉姆现在是个悲伤的家伙。”那一定是的。
And we had a fan question slash fan catch from Catherine Langridge. At four minutes, 53 seconds. Angela, did you notice that there is a Post-it note on John's computer that just says the word smile? No. It says smile. And she wrote in to say, is that a note from Jim to Jim or a note from a co-worker to Jim? Either way, Jim is a sad dude right now. It would have to be.
我觉得那是吉姆写给吉姆的，因为我的意思是，我不知道他有什么朋友会写“微笑”然后把它贴在桌子上。我不知道。我同意。我认为这只是吉姆个人状态的迹象。是的。然后安迪告诉吉姆要离那个远处的金发女郎远一点。我有点觉得那大概是安迪喜欢的人。他只是不想让吉姆去搭讪她。
I feel like it's Jim to Jim because I mean, I don't know that he has a pal that's going to write smile and stick it on his desk. I don't know. I agree. I think it's an indication that Jim's role only. Yeah. So then Andy is going to tell Jim to sort of stay away from this blonde that they can see off in the distance. I sort of felt like probably that was someone Andy liked. He just didn't want Jim to like hit on her.
噢，有道理，是的。那是为什么，因为他说：“是的，她很疯狂。离远点，驶向公海。”这把我逗乐了。这有点呼应了你刚才说的话，那就是在安迪身上，我们已经有了航海相关的梗。是的，是的。
Oh, that's a good, yeah. That's what, because he was like, yeah, she's crazy. Steer clear, head for open waters. And it cracked me up. And it kind of goes back to the thing you were saying is that already with Andy, we have the nautical references. Yes, yes. yes yes he i'm sure that andy with that whole east coast privileged life he's a he's sailing oh yeah we we learned that he's he's gonna he sails he wears all his little like outfits that
是的，他，我敢肯定安迪凭借他那种东海岸特权生活，他一定会航海。噢，是的，我们了解到他，他会航海，他穿着所有那些小衣服，
he's ready for like the boat party that's right his little dockers shoes and then we find out people wear i don't know yeah boating people we're gonna what boating people wear? I don't know. Yeah, boating people. We're going to have boating people right in. Not when I wear. And then we find out why Jim is called Big Tuna. Yes. Now, I have to ask you about this.
准备去参加那种船上派对，没错，他标志性的多克鞋。然后我们发现人们会穿，我不知道，是的，划船的人会穿什么？我不知道。是的，划船的人。我们会直接让划船的人登场。不是我穿的那种。然后我们知道了为什么吉姆被叫作“大金枪鱼”。是的。现在，我得问你这个。
I have to ask you about this. Because Andy doesn't know Jim. He really doesn't know anything about him. But he's already given him a nickname. I have someone in my life that is like this, that will give people nicknames right out of the gate. It's always really weird to me. And Jim, on his first day of work, ate a tuna sandwich and now is referred to as Big Tuna by Andy. I think somebody wrote in, and I liked this comment. I'm sorry I forgot to write down their name, but they mentioned they felt like that the
我得问你这个。因为安迪不认识吉姆。他真的对吉姆一无所知。但他已经给他起了个绰号。我生活中也有这样一个人，他一开局就会给别人起绰号。这对我来说总是真的很奇怪。而吉姆在上班的第一天吃了一个金枪鱼三明治，现在就被安迪称为“大金枪鱼”了。我想有人写信提到过，我很喜欢这个评论。抱歉我忘了记下他们的名字，但他们提到他们觉得
piece of information that Jim ate a tuna sandwich instead of his usual ham and cheese sandwich on his first day at Stanford was another way that Jim is trying to branch out, maybe that it was a subtle indication of that. I thought about that. I thought about that. But, you know, he could have had his ham sandwich and I guess Andy could have called him Hambone or something. That might have been my nickname in high school. Just going to share that with you. What? Your nickname in high school was Hambone? Well, for one year. What does that mean? What does that mean? So there was a guy named Mark and he had a party after like a football game and we all went over to his house and his parents were out of town.
吉姆在第一天去斯坦福上班时吃了一个金枪鱼三明治而不是他通常的火腿奶酪三明治这一细节，是吉姆试图拓展新事物、也许是一个微妙的暗示。我想过这个。我想过这个。但是，你知道的，他本来可以吃他的火腿三明治，我想安迪可能会叫他“火腿骨”什么的。那可能是我高中时的绰号。只想和你们分享这个。什么？你高中时的绰号是火腿骨？嗯，有一年。那是什么意思？那是什么意思？所以当时有个叫马克的人，他在一场橄榄球赛后办了一个派对，我们都去了他家，他的父母当时都不在城里。
And I was like, I'm dying. I'm just trying to figure out how ham or bone is going to come into the story. So anyway, Mark is having this party after a football game. We're all over there. His parents are out of town. I'm sure they wouldn't want us there. And I was super hungry. And I'm in like my cheerleading outfit. I'm super hungry.
我说，我快死了。我只是想弄清楚火腿或骨头是怎么扯进这个故事里的。不管怎样，马克在一场橄榄球赛后办了个派对。我们都去了。他父母不在城里。我敢肯定他们不会希望我们在那儿。我当时超级饿。我还穿着啦啦队服。我超级饿。
And I go into the kitchen and in the dark, I don't turn on any lights. And I open the fridge door. Everyone else is out on like the patio drinking beer or whatever. And I open the fridge door and there's a huge ham. Now there's a huge ham in there. And I just started eating ham standing in the fridge door with just the light of the fridge hitting me. And Mark walked in and flipped on the light and was like, Kinsey, what are you doing? I was like, I'm just eating some ham.
我走进厨房，里面黑漆漆的，我没有开灯。然后我打开了冰箱门。其他人都在外面的露台喝酒什么的。我打开冰箱门，里面有一大块火腿。里面真的有一大块火腿。我站在冰箱门前，就着冰箱里透出来的光，开始吃起火腿来。马克走进来，啪地打开灯，说：“金西，你在干嘛？”我说：“我只是吃点火腿。”
And that was it. They were like, ham bone, ham bone, ham bone. And then everyone started calling me ham bone. This is, I'm speechless. Well, all I'm saying is Andy could have called Jim ham bone, but it doesn't quite work with the whole nautical thing. So I like that this person is like, oh, Jim is starting new. He's having tuna fish sandwiches. He's working in fancy Stanford. But it also might just be that Big Tuna is funnier, given Andy's character. I've got a couple of comments about Jim's talking heads here, not to belabor, but in his one talking head, we had a fan catch from Asha Harnhart,
事情就是这样。他们就叫我：火腿骨，火腿骨，火腿骨。然后每个人都开始叫我火腿骨。这真是……我无言以对。好吧，我只想说，安迪本可以叫吉姆“火腿骨”，但跟那种航海风不太搭。所以我觉得这个人就像是在说，噢，吉姆要重新开始啦。他吃着金枪鱼三明治。他在高大上的斯坦福工作。但也有可能是因为安迪的性格，叫“大金枪鱼”更好笑。关于吉姆的访谈镜头，我这里有几个评论，不是我想啰嗦，但在他的那个访谈镜头里，我们得到了一个粉丝阿莎·哈恩哈特的发现，
who said, at four minutes, 46 seconds, Jim is explaining why he transferred to Stanford and he says that he's been promoted. But from what I can tell, it doesn't seem like his job has changed anymore. It's just the location. So was he really promoted? Yes, in the script, that talking head is extended. They cut it out for the location. So was he really promoted? Yes. In the script, that talking head is extended.
她说，在4分46秒的时候，吉姆在解释他为什么转学到斯坦福，他说他升职了。但据我所知，他的工作好像并没有什么变化，只是换了个地方。所以他真的升职了吗？是的，在剧本里，那个访谈镜头更长一些。为了剧情需要他们把这部分剪掉了。所以他真的升职了吗？是的。在剧本里，那个访谈镜头更长一些。
They cut it out for the episode. He explains that he is the assistant regional manager of Stanford. Yes. He is basically Dwight of Stanford. And there was a great deleted scene on the DVD box set. It's my favorite from this whole episode. Karen is Jim. Karen pranks Jim. She sets his dial out number to go to Hong Kong. So every time he dials out, he calls Hong Kong and he's like, what the heck? And then you see sort of like Karen's smirk and he's being pranked. And he says, I'm the assistant regional manager. And she's like, yeah, okay. So to me, in my mind, I was like, oh, my God, Jim is Dwight. Karen is Jim in this office. Angela, I think there's like a gazillion deleted scenes from this episode.
为了正片他们把它剪掉了。他解释说他是斯坦福的助理地区经理。是的。他基本上就是斯坦福的德怀特。DVD套装里有一个很棒的被删减片段。这是我整集中最喜欢的。凯伦是吉姆。凯伦捉弄吉姆。她把他的外拨电话号码设置成了打往香港。所以每次他拨外线电话，都会打到香港，然后他就会想，搞什么鬼？接着你会看到凯伦那种得意的坏笑，而他被捉弄了。他说：“我是助理地区经理。”而她却说：“行吧，好的。”所以在我的脑海里，我就想，天哪，吉姆就是德怀特。凯伦就是这个办公室里的吉姆。安吉拉，我觉得这一集有数不清的被删减片段。
There are a bunch. And it sort of like fleshes out the world of Stanford. And so I would recommend watching them. But yeah, you guys, Karen is Jim. Karen looks at Jim the way Jim used to look at Dwight and pranks him. And he's like, but I have this title. And she's like, OK. Yeah.
有很多。它有点像是丰富了斯坦福的世界。所以我会推荐大家去看一看。但是，天哪，你们大家，凯伦就是吉姆。凯伦看着吉姆的眼神，就像吉姆以前看着德怀特的那样，而且她还捉弄他。而他说：“可是我有这个头衔。”她却说：“好吧。对。”
And then later in the conference room, she's going to say he's kind of a kiss ass. Yes. Yeah. And he is kind of kissing up to his boss the way Dwight kisses up to Michael. Yeah. I have another Jenna catch about the Jim talking head. Okay. I refuse to leave this talking head.
然后后来在会议室里，她会说他有点拍马屁。对。是的。而且他确实有点在拍老板的马屁，就像德怀特拍迈克尔的马屁那样。对。关于吉姆的访谈镜头，我还有另一个珍娜的发现。好吧。我拒绝离开这个访谈镜头。
Let's keep talking about it. I noticed, we talked before about how in the Scranton branch, Jim's talking heads were always against an exterior window, whereas everybody else's talking heads faced into the office,
我们继续谈论它。我注意到，我们之前谈过，在斯克兰顿分公司，吉姆的访谈镜头背景总是对着外部的窗户，而其他所有人的访谈镜头都是面向办公室内部的，
and you could see, like, Stanley and Creed working in the background, and that the intention behind this was just for anyone who didn't hear the previous episode of this podcast that the intention was that Jim had a future outside of Scranton and so his talking heads were against a window that faced out into the world right yep Stanford, his talking heads face into the office. Come on! They face an interior window, not an exterior one.
你可以看到，比如斯坦利和克里德在背景里工作，而这样做的用意——对于任何没有听过本播客上一期节目的人来说——其用意是吉姆在斯克兰顿之外有前途，所以他的访谈镜头背对的是一扇面朝广阔世界的窗户。对吧？没错。在斯坦福，他的访谈镜头是面向办公室内部的。拜托！他们面对的是一扇内部窗户，而不是外部窗户。
He does not have a future in Stanford, everyone. Oh, girl. That is some good stuff, lady. Since we're talking about talking heads, let's talk about Andy's for a second. He says he went to Cornell. He graduated in four years. He never studied. He was drunk the whole time.
各位，他在斯坦福可没有什么前途。哦，天哪。姑娘，这可真是干货满满。既然我们在谈论访谈镜头，那我们来聊聊安迪的吧。他说他上了康奈尔大学。他四年就毕业了。他从来没学过习。他整天都在喝酒。
And he was in an acapella group called Here Comes Trouble. Well, I have a fun fact, Angela. Is it Cornell? Is it about his acapella group? Yeah. Let's hear it. Cornell does not have an acapella group called Here Comes Trouble. They don't?
而且他还加入了一个名叫“麻烦来了”的阿卡贝拉清唱团。安吉拉，我有一个冷知识。是关于康奈尔的吗？是关于他的清唱团的吗？对。说来听听。康奈尔根本没有一个叫“麻烦来了”的阿卡贝拉清唱团。没有吗？
No, it does not exist. That is up however oh my god they do have an all-female acapella group called nothing but treble nothing but treble come on and lady you know i had to investigate. Nothing But Treble was founded in 1976. You have to audition to be in the group, and they have three two-hour rehearsals per week on Tuesdays, Thursdays, and Sundays. What, did you go to their website? You looked up their rehearsal schedule? Lady, not only did I spend about 45 minutes on their website, I reached out to them.
不，根本没有。不过，天哪，他们确实有一个全女生的阿卡贝拉清唱团，叫做“纯粹高音”，纯粹高音！拜托，大家知道我得去查证一下。“纯粹高音”成立于1976年。你必须通过试镜才能加入这个组合，他们每周二、周四和周日要进行三次两小时的排练。什么，你上了他们的网站？你查了他们的排练时间表？姑娘，我不仅在他们的网站上花了大约45分钟，我还联系了他们。
Aka what? Yeah, and they sent me a clip of themselves singing Britney Spears' Hit Me Baby One More Time. Sam, roll it. was I supposed to know? That something wasn't right yet. Oh, baby, baby, I shouldn't let go. It's seriously so good. It is aka awesome. It's aka awesome. Guys, this badass group of women can be found on Instagram at nbt-cornell, or you can download
也就是什么？对，他们给我发了一段他们唱小甜甜布兰妮的《Hit Me Baby One More Time》的片段。萨姆，放出来听听。我怎么会知道呢？事情有点不对劲。哦，宝贝，宝贝，我不该放手。这真的太棒了。简直太棒了。简直太棒了。伙计们，这个超酷的女性组合可以在Instagram上的nbt-cornell找到，或者你也可以在Spotify上的“纯粹高音”下载
their music at Nothing But Treble on Spotify. That's awesome. I might have done that. I might have done that. You might have done it. I think you did. You know when their rehearsal schedule is.
他们的音乐。太棒了。我可能真的这么做了。我可能真的这么做了。你可能真的做了。我觉得你做了。你连他们的排练时间都知道。
I might have their whole album now. What are you going to do? Join their Zoom rehearsal schedule this week? You know, I just might. I just might. Okay. Well, while we're talking talking heads, I want to talk about Karen's talking head.
我现在可能拥有他们的整张专辑了。你打算怎么办？这周去加入他们的Zoom排练吗？你知道吗，我可能真的会。我可能真的会。好吧。在我们讨论访谈镜头的时候，我想谈谈凯伦的访谈镜头。
Karen's talking head. You guys go to six minutes, 17 seconds for a fantastic impression of Jim's look to camera. Rashida Jones crushes it. She looks to camera and goes, and he's always doing this. And she does his face and she goes, what's that about? Like, what is that? It's so good. So I texted Rashida and I was like, Rashida, I am watching you right now.
凯伦的访谈镜头。大家快去看6分17秒，里面对吉姆对着镜头看的表情进行了精彩的模仿。拉什达·琼斯绝了。她看着镜头说：“而且他总是这样。”然后她模仿他的表情说：“那是什么意思啊？”就像，那到底是什么？太棒了。所以我给拉什达发信息说：“拉什达，我正在看你现在的表演。”
Do your impression of Jim's look to camera. And it is cracking me up. You crushed it. And she was like, oh, my gosh, Ange, that's so nice. She said, I was so damn nervous. She told me she was convinced that she was going to get fired. She also said originally the character was written to be more ornery, sour and mean. Those were her exact words. And she said, she said, that's why my bangs are sort of like
模仿一下吉姆看着镜头的表情。这快把我笑死了。你演得太棒了。然后她说：“哦，天哪，安吉，你太好了。”她说：“我当时紧张得要命。”她告诉我，她确信自己会被炒鱿鱼。她还说，原本这个角色被写得更加粗暴、刻薄和卑劣。这是她的原话。她说，她说，这就是为什么我的刘海有点像
pinned to my forehead and I'm not wearing hardly any makeup. They just thought that Karen was going to be maybe a little bit more gruff and kind of a meanie. And then she said that Greg decided to soften her. And so in the next episode, she's a little softer. She's not quite so sour. That is so interesting. You know, Angela, I was brought in over the summer to screen test with a bunch of different Karens. And Rashida was one of them. So they had whittled it down to three Karens. And I had to come in and I had to read scenes with them as Pam. They wrote this scene that was never shot. It was a Karen Pam scene that you never see, but they just wrote it for the purposes of the audition. And I had to come in and read. And at the end of it all, they said, who did you like best?
别在额头上，而且我几乎没怎么化妆。他们只是觉得凯伦可能会稍微生硬一点，而且有点刻薄。然后她说格里格决定让她变得柔和一些。所以在下一集中，她变得温柔了一点。她没那么刻薄了。这太有趣了。你知道吗，安吉拉，夏天的时候我被叫去和一堆不同的“凯伦”进行试镜。拉什达就是其中之一。所以他们把人选缩小到了三个“凯伦”。我不得不去那里，以帕姆的身份和她们对词。他们写了一场从未被拍摄的戏。那是帕姆和凯伦的一场戏，你从未见过，但他们只是为了试镜的目的写了这场戏。我不得不去试镜。在这一切结束时，他们问：“你最喜欢谁？”
And I said, my favorite was Rashida Jones. She just made me feel, it was that same thing that I've said about John. When I met John, there was this instant chemistry because he made it the easiest to be Pam. And that's how I described it to them. I said, I just didn't even feel like I had to work hard in my scenes with her. I effortlessly felt this chemistry between Pam and Karen. I knew who Pam and Karen were and who they were going to be. I also think from that
我说：“我最喜欢拉什达·琼斯。”她只是让我感觉……这和我之前对约翰说过的是同一个感觉。当我遇到约翰时，有一种瞬间的化学反应，因为他让扮演帕姆变得最轻松。我就是这样向他们描述的。我说，我甚至觉得和她对戏时我不需要付出什么努力。我毫不费力地就感受到了帕姆和凯伦之间的这种化学反应。我知道帕姆和凯伦是谁，以及她们将会成为谁。我也觉得从
first moment in that audition, Angela, I immediately saw her as a little bit of like this shiny object that I admired. She was such a cool woman that I was like, oh, that's a good dynamic for Pam and Karen too. Because I think Pam does look at Karen as a woman she would aspire to be. Karen has an inner confidence. She has ambition that she's not afraid of. And so I felt all of that at play, even from our very first time meeting. And I was just so excited because I didn't think they would necessarily care who I thought was the person I responded the most to, but it made me so excited when she was cast. So it's funny to me that she thought she was going to get fired because I remember all the conversations about her audition and how everyone was like, she is it. She is Karen.
在试镜的那个最初时刻起，安吉拉，我立刻就把她看作是一个我所仰慕的闪闪发光的对象。她是如此一个酷炫的女性，以至于我想，噢，这对帕姆和凯伦来说也是一个很好的动态关系。因为我觉得帕姆确实把凯伦看作是她渴望成为的那种女性。凯伦有一种内在的自信。她有着不畏惧的野心。所以我从我们第一次见面时就感受到了所有这些化学反应在起作用。我当时太兴奋了，因为我没想到他们会在乎谁是我最有共鸣的人，但当她被选中时，我真的超级兴奋。所以我觉得很有趣的是，她以为自己会被开除，因为我记得所有关于她试镜的讨论，大家都说：她就是这个人。她就是凯伦。
She is the one. Well, she texted me that she did not sleep probably the whole week before her first day of filming. And she said she had just like major panic that the viewers were going to hate her because Karen gets in the middle between Pam and Jim. And she was like, oh, my God, they're all going to hate me. Well, you know, Rashida and I used to talk about that. And eventually there's like a whole thing where it was team Pam, team Karen. And I told her, I don't know. I have to be honest with you.
她就是那个不二人选。嗯，她给我发信息说，在她拍摄第一天前的那个星期，她大概整晚都没合眼。她说她有一种极度的恐慌，担心观众会讨厌她，因为凯伦插在了帕姆和吉姆中间。她说：“哦，天哪，他们都会讨厌我的。”嗯，你知道的，拉什达和我以前经常谈论这个。最后甚至出现了一种整个局势分为“帕姆派”和“凯伦派”的现象。我告诉她：“我不知道。我得跟你说实话。”
If I was watching this, I might actually be team Karen. I might. Yeah. Even though I am Pam. So I told her, don't worry about it. There's going to be plenty of people who know you're just a great lady. So yeah, I told Rashida, I thought she did a great job. I mean, Karen is a really tough role because she treads on the sacred ground that is Jim
如果我在看这部剧，我实际上可能会支持凯伦派。我可能会。是的。尽管我是帕姆。所以我告诉她：“别担心。会有很多人知道你只是一个非常好的女士。”所以，是的，我告诉拉什达，我觉得她做得很好。我的意思是，凯伦是一个非常难演的角色，因为她踩到了吉姆
and Pam. But I thought she was a fantastic foil. And Rashida said that she would love to come on the show. She said maybe Benihana Christmas would be fun. Yes. So we're going to get Rashida on here too. And Rashida, thankana Christmas would be fun. Yes. So we're going to get Rashida on here too. And Rashida, thank you so much. I love her. I know. All right. Should we go back to the Scranton branch and talk about Michael and Dwight spying on everyone from
和帕姆之间的神圣领地。但我认为她是一个极好的衬托。拉什达说她很乐意来参加节目。她说也许《班尼哈纳圣诞节》会很有趣。是的。所以我们也会把拉什达请到这里来。拉什达，非常感谢你。我太喜欢她了。我懂。好吧。我们是不是应该回到斯克兰顿分公司，聊聊迈克尔和德怀特在
inside of Michael's office? Oh, do you mean what I titled getting cocky? Oh, explain. At six minutes, 56 seconds, you know, Michael's suggesting who he thinks might be gay in the office. He says maybe Angela. And Dwight looks very smugly to camera and says, I really don't think so. And look like that Angela isn't gay and he knows why.
迈克尔办公室里监视每个人？哦，你是说我起名为“变得自大”的那段吗？哦，解释一下。在6分56秒时，你知道的，迈克尔在猜测办公室里谁可能是同性恋。他说也许是安吉拉。德怀特非常自鸣得意地看着镜头说：“我真的不这么觉得。”并且露出那种安吉拉绝不是同性恋、而且他知道原因的表情。
But he gives a total look straight to camera, really smug and cocky. I'm like, Dwight, what are you doing? Yeah. Dwight, we are in a secret relationship. You don't get to give a little wink wink to the cameraman. What is he doing? Yeah. He's getting cocky.
但他直接看着镜头，露出了一个非常自鸣得意、傲慢的表情。我当时想：德怀特，你在干什么？是的。德怀特，我们在谈地下恋爱。你不能对摄像师抛媚眼啊。他在干什么？对。他变得自大了。
He's getting cocky. We know that the camera people know because they found you in that playhouse. But you guys don't know that they know. Dwight doesn't know. So why is he giving the little smug wink look to camera? He couldn't help himself. He couldn't help himself. He couldn't do it. He's delighted to be in this relationship with you, Angela. I know. I know. Well, they also talk about gaydar, that Jim told Dwight that you can buy a device that tells you whether or not someone is gay. They decide they need to get it, so they call Jim.
他变得自大了。我们知道摄像人员知道，因为他们在那个儿童剧场里发现了你们。但你们并不知道他们知道。德怀特不知道。那他为什么还要对着镜头露出那种自鸣得意的抛媚眼表情？他克制不住自己。他克制不住自己。他忍不住。他很高兴能和你有这段恋情，安吉拉。我知道。我知道。嗯，他们还谈到了“同性恋雷达”，吉姆告诉德怀特，你可以买一个设备来检测某人是不是同性恋。他们决定搞一个，所以他们给吉姆打了电话。
someone is gay. They decide they need to get it. So they call Jim. And this was a thing that they did so that they could keep up this little pranky relationship and keep Jim part of our world so that you could see and you'll see this going forward in season three. There are going to be ways, especially even in the next episode, there's going to be a convention and Jim is going to go on this convention and be reunited with Michael. And so anyway, they did they did want to find even in this episode ways that Jim was connected back to Scranton and back to Michael and Dwight. Yeah, they did it with Gaydar. They did it with Gaydar and they also did it with Mr. Brown having to come in and talk about, you know, sort of like a type of diversity training.
某人是不是同性恋。他们决定搞一个。所以他们给吉姆打了电话。他们这么做是为了维持这种恶作剧式的关系，让吉姆继续留在我们的世界里，这样你就能看到——而且你在第三季中会看到这一点。会有一些方式，甚至在下一集中，会有一个会议，吉姆将去参加这个会议，并与迈克尔重聚。所以无论如何，他们确实希望甚至在这集中找到让吉姆重新与斯克兰顿、与迈克尔和德怀特联系起来的方式。是的，他们通过“同性恋雷达”做到了。他们通过“同性恋雷达”做到了，而且他们还通过布朗先生进来谈论，你知道的，某种多元化培训来做到这一点。
Right. And it's because the Scranton branch is acting up again. Yeah. and talk about, you know, sort of like a type of diversity training, right? And it's because the Scranton branch is acting up again. Yeah. So there's a lot of moments where you get to see Jim thinking about Scranton, Jim thinking about Pam, Jim even missing Dwight and Michael. And this is one of those moments. And I wrote that at seven minutes, 29 seconds, I think it's the first time Jim truly looks happy in this whole episode because he gets to talk to Dwight and Michael and like sort
没错。因为斯克兰顿分公司又开始胡闹了。是的。谈论，你知道的，某种多元化培训，对吧？因为斯克兰顿分公司又开始胡闹了。是的。所以有很多时刻，你可以看到吉姆在想念斯克兰顿，吉姆在想念帕姆，吉姆甚至在想念德怀特和迈克尔。这就是其中一个时刻。我写道，在7分29秒时，我认为这是吉姆在整集中第一次真正看起来很高兴，因为他又可以和德怀特、迈克尔说话，并且再次
of laugh at what idiots they are once again. So now we know that Pam said she was going to marry Roy. We know that Jim has moved to Stanford, but now we're going to learn more about Pam's relationship. Pam is at her desk. Roy enters with two plates of food. He asks her if she wants chicken or fish. They have a little awkward small talk
嘲笑他们是多么白痴。现在我们知道了帕姆说她要嫁给罗伊。我们知道吉姆已经搬到了斯坦福，但现在我们要更多地了解帕姆的恋情。帕姆坐在办公桌前。罗伊端着两盘食物走进来。他问她想吃鸡肉还是鱼肉。他们进行了有点尴尬的闲聊，
and then the camera pushes in to Pam's left hand. No ring. This whole time she didn't have a ring on. I didn't even notice, right? Yeah. So when that happened, I really did. Even though I knew it because you and I know the show, I was like, oh, no ring. Oh, my God. Ring. No ring. And also really tan Roy, very tan and in shape Roy. Roy's looking amazing. He's
然后镜头推向帕姆的左手。没有戒指。这么长时间她手上一直没有戴戒指。我甚至都没注意到，对吧？是的。所以当那一幕发生时，我是真的……尽管我知道，因为你和我都了解这部剧，但我还是觉得：哦，没有戒指。天哪。有戒指。没有戒指。还有，晒得很健康的罗伊，身材超级棒、晒得很健康的罗伊。罗伊看起来太棒了。他
looking really good. David Denman is a tall drink of water when he walks the man that pam didn't marry is now suddenly super hot he's tan and in really good shape and the beard i'm i'm living for that beard it's all working david it was all working well pam explains that she did not go through with the wedding she got cold feet and just like the weeks before. Right. And she just knew she had to get out of the relationship. She explains that they still had to pay for all the food. So they froze it. And now I guess she has to eat chicken or fish every day for the next five weeks. I thought that was really funny detail. It's very funny. five weeks. I thought that was really funny detail. It's very funny. And, you know, then Roy has a talking head and he broke my heart. He gets emotional. He says he's got to get her back,
看起来状态极佳。大卫·丹曼走起路来就像一把身高马大的高脚杯，那个帕姆没有嫁的男人现在突然变得超级性感，他皮肤晒得黝黑，身材超棒，还有那胡子，我简直太爱那胡子了。这一切都绝配，大卫，全都配极了。嗯，帕姆解释说她没有完成婚礼。她临阵退缩了，就像前几周那样。没错。她只是知道她必须逃离这段关系。她解释说他们还得付所有的食物钱。所以他们把它冻起来了。现在我想她不得不在接下来的五周里每天都吃鸡肉或鱼肉。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的细节。非常搞笑。接下来的五周。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的细节。非常搞笑。而且，你知道的，然后罗伊有一个访谈镜头，他让我心碎了。他变得情绪激动。他说他要把她追回来，
you know, and he's not going to take her for granted. And I was like, oh, my gosh, super hot tan in shape. Roy is now getting emotional. What the heck is happening? I know he explains that he got arrested for a DUI. I remember that DUI photo because I remember them like deciding which one to pick. And I remember that one made us laugh and Mindy was like cackling.
你知道的，他不会再把她视为理所当然。当时我就想：哦，天哪，超级性感、皮肤黝黑、身材健美的罗伊现在竟然情绪激动了。到底发生了什么？我知道他解释说他因为酒驾被捕了。我记得那张酒驾照片，因为我记得当时他们好像在讨论该选哪一张。我还记得那张照片把我们逗笑了，明迪笑得前仰后合。
I remember the same thing. I remember the same thing. We had a fan question from Rihanna Sheriff who said, how did they make the mugshot of Roy? Well, listen, here's the thing. David shot a movie over the summer and he got into that like super amazing shape for that movie. Right. And he came back for season three of The Office and he, as we have discussed, looked amazing. And Greg was like, oh, no, we had written you as having sort of fallen apart as a result of your broken engagement to Pam.
我也记得。我也记得。我们有一个来自蕾安娜·谢里夫的粉丝提问，她说：“罗伊的通缉犯大头照是怎么做出来的？”好吧，听着，事情是这样的。大卫夏天拍了一部电影，为了那部电影他练出了那种超级棒的身材。没错。他回到了《办公室》第三季，正如我们所讨论的那样，他看起来棒极了。格里格就说：“哦，不，我们把你剧本里的人设定为由于和帕姆解除婚约而有点崩溃了。”
So they had to kind of rewrite it a little bit. They wanted to keep in that whole bit about how he had been arrested. So they took a picture of him. And then with Photoshop, they like swelled up his face. They blew out his neck. It was so weird. It was so crazy. And they brought around like six different options for all of us to vote on which one we liked.
所以他们不得不稍微重写了一点剧本。他们想保留他被捕的那段剧情。所以他们拍了一张他的照片。然后用Photoshop，把他的脸P肿了。把他的脖子P粗了。太诡异了。太疯狂了。他们拿出了大约六种不同的选项，让我们所有人投票选出我们最喜欢哪一个。
I totally remember that too, Angela. Yeah, we were cracking up. Oh my God. It was amazing. Roy is hot. Okay. He's trying to turn a corner here for Pam. But there is someone who has a gripe with them.
我完全也记得那个，安吉拉。是的，我们当时笑翻了。天哪。太绝了。罗伊很性感。好吧。他在这里正试图为帕姆改过自新。但有一个人对他们有意见。
And it is Stanley. Yeah. Because Stanley bought them a toaster for their wedding. Then they call off their wedding, and he tried to return the toaster, and the store won't take it back. And you know what I think? What? I think Stanley, because he's cheap, we sort of have established that he's kind of cheap, right? Yeah.
那就是斯坦利。是的。因为斯坦利在他们婚礼时买了一个烤面包机送给他们。然后他们取消了婚礼，他试图退掉那个烤面包机，但商店不给退。你们知道我在想什么吗？什么？我猜斯坦利，因为他很抠门，我们之前已经建立过他人设，他有点抠门，对吧？是的。
I think that Stanley bought them a discontinued toaster, like the toaster that was on sale, like clearance. He bought them the crap toaster in his bum that he couldn't return it. Well, then he deserves to be stuck with two toasters, doesn't he? That's what you get. Oh, hey, we don't have a sting for this, but I would like to put in a sting at nine minutes, 34 seconds that goes something like a full Mindy. We need a full Mindy sting. We need to get on that immediately, actually, because at nine minutes, 34 seconds, we see some real long extensions. Oh, yeah. And a bright green blouse and a floral skirt. It is full, full Mandy. There's no going back. There's no going back. full band-aid there's no going back there's no going back also she like skips up to oscar's desk and she just wants to tell him how cool it is that he's gay and how she has totally underestimated
我觉得斯坦利买给他们的其实是一个停产的烤面包机，就像那种在促销的、清仓的烤面包机。他送了他们一个破烂烤面包机，活该他退不掉。那他活该砸手里有两个烤面包机，不是吗？这就是你应得的。哦，嘿，我们没有为此准备音频转场，但我希望在9分34秒处加入一个音频转场，听起来就像一个“完整版明迪”。我们需要一个“完整版明迪”的音频转场。我们实际上需要立刻着手做这个，因为在9分34秒，我们看到了一些非常长的接发。哦，是的。还有一件亮绿色的衬衫和一条碎花裙。这就是彻头彻尾、原汁原味的明迪。没有回头路了。没有回头路了。彻头彻尾的明迪，没有回头路了。没有回头路了。而且她还一蹦一跳地走到奥斯卡的办公桌前，她只是想告诉他他是同性恋有多么酷，以及她是如何完全低估了
him and then oscar has that amazing talking to head that is so that tickles me where he says he yes he's very very cool because he's an accountant at a failing paper supply company in Scranton, much like Sir Ian McKellen. Yeah. Yeah. And then, you know, we cut to my character who's just glaring at him and being just not nice, you guys. And I'm applying hand sanitizer. And we do find out in this episode that I think Will and Grace is very loud and that I like Harry Connick Jr. Yeah, you're not a fan of Will and Grace, but you do like Harry Connick Jr. Send me some Harry Connick.
他，然后奥斯卡就有了那个精彩绝伦、让人忍俊不禁的访谈镜头，他说他——是的，他非常非常酷，因为他在斯克兰顿一家快要倒闭的纸品公司当会计，就像伊恩·麦克莱恩爵士一样。对。对。然后，你知道的，镜头切到了我的角色，正狠狠地瞪着他，而且对人家一点也不友好，伙计们。我还在涂洗手液。我们在这一集里确实发现，我觉得《威尔和格蕾丝》太吵了，而且我喜欢小哈里·康尼克。是的，你不是《威尔和格蕾丝》的粉丝，但你确实喜欢小哈里·康尼克。给我来点哈里·康尼克。
Well, then at 10 minutes, eight seconds, Meredith pumps some of Angela's hand sanitizer into her hand and then licks it off. All right, fan question from Natasha Rahaman. What did Meredith actually eat when she is shown eating the hand sanitizer? Oh, good question, Natasha. Natasha, I am so glad you asked this question because I actually wondered the same thing when I was watching the scene.
好吧，然后在10分08秒，梅雷迪思挤了一些安吉拉的洗手液到手里，然后舔掉了。好的，来自娜塔莎·拉哈曼的粉丝提问：梅雷迪思在被展示吃洗手液时，实际上吃的是什么？哦，好问题，娜塔莎。娜塔莎，我很高兴你问了这个问题，因为我自己在看这场戏时其实也有同样的疑问。
Here's the thing. I think Meredith thinks she can get a buzz off of it because she's, you know, she thinks there's alcohol in it, right? So yeah, she's like, I'm gonna have some hand sanitizer. Well, I was texting with Kate Flannery yesterday. And I said, Kate, you've got to give us the lowdown. What was in the hand sanitizer? Tell us all the details. Did she tell you? Well, guess what she did? She was like, Ange, I will leave you a message about it. And I was like, oh, okay, even better. So she left me a message and she said we can play it here. So Sam, play Kate's answer.
事情是这样的。我觉得梅雷迪思以为她能借此获得一点微醺的感觉，因为她，你知道的，她觉得里面有酒精，对吧？所以，是的，她就像是：我要来点洗手液。好吧，我昨天跟凯特·弗兰纳里发短信了。我说：“凯特，你得跟我们交个底。洗手液里到底是什么？把所有细节都告诉我们。”她告诉你了吗？嗯，你猜她怎么说？她说：“安吉，我会给你留个语音留言。”我就想：“哦，好吧，那更好了。”所以她给我留了一条语音留言，说我们可以把它在这里放出来。所以，萨姆，播放凯特的回答。
Hey, everybody. It's Kate Flannery. And I'm here to answer a fantastic question from one of the fans of the Office Ladies podcast. And I have a feeling I know who this is from. Is this from Big Tool 9 at AOL? I think he asked me the same question a long time ago. Okay. Anyway, what did Meredith actually eat when she's shown eating the hand sanitizer? So they actually changed what was in the bottle. They put gelatin with club soda. So it had the bubbles. So it was just clear gelatin, but they put it back in the same bottle that the original hand sanitizer came in, which
大家好。我是凯特·弗兰纳里。我来回答《办公室女士》播客粉丝的一个精彩提问。我有种感觉，我知道这是谁问的。这是来自AOL的Big Tool 9吗？我想他很久以前也问过我同样的问题。好吧。不管怎样，梅雷迪思吃洗手液的时候到底吃的是什么？其实他们换了瓶子里的东西。他们用苏打水做了明胶冻。所以它有气泡。它其实就是透明的果冻，但他们把它装回了原来那个装洗手液的瓶子里，那个瓶子
is very perfumey. So when I went to lick it off my hand, it tasted like perfume. So it was kind of gross. And I think we did maybe four or five takes. So there was no cheap high involved. I mean, I'm a big Jell-O fan, but I like a little flavor and I don't particularly like perfumey flavor. Anyway, that's just my taste. Thank you for asking. Are you sure this wasn't big tool nine at AOL? Yeah, I get a lot of questions online
气味非常浓烈。所以当我把它从手上舔下来的时候，尝起来像香水。所以感觉有点恶心。我想我们大概拍了四五条。所以里面并没有什么廉价的快感。我的意思是，我是一个狂热的果冻迷，但我喜欢带点味道的，而且我特别不喜欢香水味的果冻。不管怎样，这只是我的个人口味。谢谢你的提问。你确定这不是AOL的Big Tool 9吗？是的，我在网上收到了很多来自
from whoever that is. Okay, all the best. Love you guys. Woo-hoo. Wish we were physically together. Kate, thank you. It just made me laugh that that here's kate kate always has a bit you know and so like i love that even in answering this she had her bit about the guy that big tool whatever who kept like writing into her tool nine big tool nine
不管是谁发来的问题。好吧，祝一切都好。爱你们哟。呜呼。真希望我们能实体聚在一起。凯特，谢谢你。这让我觉得很好笑，凯特总是能抛出一个梗，你知道的，所以——我喜欢她在回答这个问题时，也拿那个经常给她写信的家伙开玩笑，那个叫什么Big Tool的……Tool 9，Big Tool 9！
guys come on why couldn't they have put it in a bottle that had been rinsed out or something? I don't know. I just want to say that this is like a two second joke. Like this is it. This is not a runner. She doesn't go around the office looking at this was just like a little moment. It is in the script. And when I think of moments like this, I just think of all the planning that went in to making something for her to eat.
伙计们，拜托，他们难道不能把它装在一个冲洗干净的瓶子里或者别的什么东西里吗？我不知道。我只想说这只是一个两秒钟的笑话。就是这样。这不是一个贯穿全剧的常驻笑料。她没有在办公室里到处看着这个，这只是一个小小的时刻。剧本里确实有。每当我想到这样的时刻，我就会想到为制作一样供她食用的东西所投入的所有前期策划。
And I actually texted Phil Shea. And I was like, Phil, what is it like when you get a script and there's this little tiny joke and it sends you down this road? And he said these are his favorite moments because it's a challenge and that he read this and he was like, all right, time to find edible hand sanitizer. and that he read this and he was like, all right, time to find edible hand sanitizer. And I sort of found it interesting that they had to put like a sparkly, like water, like seltzer in it, because I bet once they added the gelatin, there were no bubbles and hand sanitizer has bubbles. So that is like such a small, tiny amount of detail that they were like,
我实际上给菲尔·谢伊发了短信。我说：“菲尔，当你拿到剧本，里面有这么个微不足道的小笑话，然后让你走上这样一条奇葩的道路时，是什么感觉？”他说这是他最喜欢的时刻，因为这是一种挑战，他读到这的时候就想：“好吧，是时候去找可食用的洗手液了。”
nope, we didn't get it right. Let's add the seltzer. Well, I'll have you know, I noticed the bubbles and it really threw me because it made me think that Kate was really eating hand sanitizer, which I knew she couldn't possibly. They would never make her do that. And I asked Phil Shea about that. And he said at first they tried just clear agave syrup. Just like a clear agave, you know, because it's thick and sweet but no bubbles you say syrup very midwesty how do you say it syrup no no no i think what you mean is i say syrup correctly
而且我觉得挺有意思的是，他们还得在里面加一点亮晶晶的、像水一样苏打水，因为我敢肯定一旦他们加入了明胶果冻，就没有任何气泡了，而洗手液是有气泡的。所以这真的是一个极其微小的细节，他们却觉得：“不，我们没做好。加上苏打水。”好吧，我要告诉你，我注意到了气泡，这真的把我弄糊涂了，因为它让我以为凯特真的在吃洗手液，而我知道她绝对不可能这样做。他们绝不会让她做那种事的。我问过菲尔·谢伊这件事。他说一开始他们只尝试了透明的龙舌兰糖浆。就像透明的龙舌兰一样，你知道的，因为它又浓又甜，但没有气泡。你说糖浆（syrup）的发音好中西部风哦。你是怎么发音的？糖浆（syrup）。不，不，不，我的意思是我是正确地发音为“糖浆”（syrup），
and you say syrup okay all right like like a southerner. And excuse me. I'm not saying it's good or bad. I'm just saying you are saying it incorrectly. Really quickly, before we get off on a huge tangent of our syrup and syrup and syrup like debate. Kate told me that she's really proud of the fact that she did her stunts. She did a lot of her own stunts. The majority of all the things that you see that happens to Meredith, Kate did a pass at that. And so she was like, this was just another one of those. When I got the script, I was like, okay, what am I going to be licking? What is it? I don't think anyone in the cast was subjected to more stunts than Kate, actually.
而你发音为“糖浆”（syrup）。好吧，好吧，就像南方人那样。打扰一下。我没说它好还是不好。我只是说你发音不正确。等一下，在我们陷入关于“syrup”和“syrup”的巨大题外话之前……凯特告诉我，她为自己能亲自完成特技而感到非常自豪。她做了很多自己的特技。你看到的绝大多数发生在梅雷迪思身上的事情，都是凯特亲自上阵的。所以她当时就觉得：这只是其中之一而已。当我拿到剧本时，我就想：好吧，我这次要舔什么？这是什么？我觉得剧组里没有任何人比凯特承受过更多的特技了，真的。
No, no one was. Maybe Steve. Maybe Steve. But Kate, I think, is actually number one. I think she's number one. And she was a really good sport about it. And Kate, thank you so much for sending in that message. Thank you, Kate.
不，没有人。也许斯蒂芬有过。也许斯蒂芬有。但凯特，我觉得真的是第一名。我觉得她是第一名。而且她对此真的很有体育精神。凯特，非常感谢你发来这条语音。谢谢你，凯特。
And thank you again, Natasha. All right, so now we're back. We're at 10 minutes, 37 seconds. And we get a real bird's eye view of Andy's temper because someone has put his calculator in Jell-O and he kind of freaks out. He does freak out. He kicks the trash can. I'll have you know that was not in the script.
也再次谢谢娜塔莎。好了，现在我们回来了。时间来到10分37秒。我们看到了安迪暴脾气的一个真正全貌，因为有人把他的计算器放进了果冻里，他有点抓狂了。他确实抓狂了。他踢了垃圾桶。我要告诉你们，那可不在剧本里。
And when I was texting with Ed, he told me that they came up with that on the set. He remembered Mike Schur being on set and throwing out a bunch of funny ideas. And in this moment, this was one of those moments where they were able to say like, okay, how much, how big of a reaction can Andy have to this jello thing? And he was like, how about I kick the trash can? They were like, try it. And it made it in. And he was super excited because it was kind of like his first improv moment that made it in an episode. Yeah, I love it. I thought it was perfect. And it really was like, oh, this guy is unhinged. Yeah, he's not OK. Well, I noticed a really random thing over his shoulder when he starts talking about the calculator on his computer it says table of
当我跟埃德发短信时，他告诉我那是他们在片场临场发挥想出来的。他记得迈克·舒尔当时在片场，抛出了很多有趣的创意。而在这一刻，这就是他们能够说“好吧，安迪对这个果冻事件能做出多大、多夸张的反应呢？”的时刻之一，然后他就说：“我踢垃圾桶怎么样？”他们说：“试试看吧。”结果这个镜头就留在了正片里。他当时超级兴奋，因为这可以说是他第一个进入正片的即兴发挥时刻。对，我超爱。我觉得太完美了。这真的很像是：“哦，这家伙精神失常了。”是的，他不太正常。嗯，我注意到当他开始谈论电脑上的计算器时，他肩膀上方有一个非常随机的东西，上面写着“目录”。
contents i saw that too i'm like is andy writing a book is he reading what is he looking at is it a manual what is it and i watched the deleted scenes i thought maybe there might be some reference to it but there wasn't so i thought that was kind of interesting i'm like what is that about remains a mystery mystery so now we're going to go back again to the Scranton branch. Jan has arrived. Yeah. They had to call in the big guns because things are going off the rails here. So Jan is not happy.
我也看到了。我当时想：安迪是在写书吗？他在看什么？他在看什么手册吗？那是什么？我还看了被删减的片段，我以为可能会有什么相关的参考，但并没有。所以我觉得这挺有意思的，我想：那到底是什么鬼？依然是个谜。一个谜。所以现在我们要再次回到斯克兰顿分公司。简来了。是的。他们不得不搬出重兵出击，因为事情已经彻底失控了。所以简很不高兴。
No. Toby explains that now Oscar is basically feeling discriminated against by everyone in the office, particularly Angela. Yeah. And Michael needs to do something about it. Yeah. So Michael calls Oscar into his office. Oh, man. And Oscar says to Michael, am I the first gay man that you've ever known? Yeah. Is this is this what is happening right now? Yeah. And they're they seem like they might be about to have this very productive heart-to-heart when Pam comes in to announce that Dwight is looking at gay porn on his computer. Because that's what Michael asked him to do.
没有。托比解释说，现在奥斯卡觉得自己受到了办公室里所有人的歧视，尤其是安吉拉。是的。而迈克尔需要对此采取点行动。是的。所以迈克尔把奥斯卡叫进了他的办公室。天哪。奥斯卡对迈克尔说：“我是你认识的第一个同性恋吗？”是的。难道——难道现在发生的就是这个吗？是的。而且他们看起来好像正要进行一次非常富有成效的真诚交谈，这时帕姆走进来宣布德怀特正在他的电脑上看同性恋色情片。因为那是迈克尔让他这么做的。
This is how Michael thinks he's going to problem solve? Yeah. First of all, he shouldn't be looking at pornography at work. Any pornography. Any pornography. Why would he ever think this is acceptable to try to remedy a situation? Oh my gosh. Michael, Michael, Michael. Because Michael says, hey, there is nothing wrong with it. Gay porn, straight porn. It's all good. Yeah. It's all good. And at work at work,
这就是迈克尔以为他能解决问题的方式？首先，他不应该在工作时看色情片。任何色情片。任何色情片。他怎么会认为用这种方式来弥补局面是可以接受的？哦，天哪。迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔。因为迈克尔说：“嘿，这没什么不对的。同性恋色情片，异性恋色情片。都没差啦。”是的。都没差。而在工作时间，
what is happening? So they're all gathered around Dwight's desk. And anyway, Oscar walks up and he's like, what are you guys doing? And then Angela has a really snarky line where she's like, oh, watching some of your friends. Oh, yeah. So snarky. And he kind of shoves past her. Oh, lady, we had a fan question about that. Anthony Giratano said, how much choreography was involved in Oscar pushing you, Angela? Was this planned? Here's the thing. It really does
这到底在干什么？所以他们都聚集在德怀特的办公桌周围。不管怎样，奥斯卡走过来，他说：“你们在干什么？”然后安吉拉有一句非常刻薄的台词，她说：“哦，在看你的一些朋友呗。”哦，对。太刻薄了。然后他从她身边挤了过去。哦，天哪，我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问。安东尼·吉拉塔诺说：“奥斯卡推你安吉拉的时候，排练了多少次？这是计划好的吗？”事情是这样的。这真的
look like he kind of shoves me aside. But the direction we were given is that my character is really playing up the drama of this moment. Almost like when you watch like a soccer match and someone barely gets nudged and they have the big ball like, ah, that's how Ken directed me, that Oscar would just really barely brush by me. And I'd be like, oh, don't touch me, you know? Yes. Well, this is what I was talking about in the cliffhanger little moment
看起来他好像把我推到了一边。但我们得到的导演指导是，我的角色在这场戏里把戏剧效果拉满了。有点像你看足球比赛时，某人几乎没被碰到，却做出巨大的夸张反应：“啊——！”肯就是这样指导我的，他说奥斯卡只是非常轻微地从我身边擦过，而我会说：“哦，别碰我，”你知道的？是的。好吧，这就是我在上一集的悬念小彩蛋里谈到的，
I left in the last episode where I was like, okay, this is what I was talking about in the cliffhanger little moment I left in the last episode where I was like, okay, this is when I went to Greg. There was another line and I can't remember what it was, but it was something like sort of like, well, I think Jesus would be disappointed in you or something like that. I just went to Greg and I was like, Greg, you know, I grew up going to church and I go to church and I, that's just not the message I received, grew up going to church and I go to church and I, that's just not the message I received, you know, about Jesus. And I just, I just don't think that's how Angela Martin would think. I mean, she can be judgy all she wants, but I don't think that's how she thinks. Her way that she is, how she's kind of uptight and judgy and all of that is separate from her
我留在上一集的悬念里说：“好吧，这就是我在跟格里格交流时谈到的内容。”当时还有另一句台词，我记不清具体是什么了，但大概是“嗯，我觉得耶稣会对你感到失望的”之类的。我直接去找格里格，我说：“格里格，你知道的，我是去教堂长大的，我也一直在去教堂，我……这根本不是我从教堂、从耶稣那里得到的讯息，你知道的。而且我只是——我只是不认为安吉拉·马丁会这么想。我的意思是，她想怎么评判别人都可以，但我认为她不会那样想。她那种一本正经、爱评头论足等等的性格，是和她的
religion. And I think that's what you were wanting to do. You were wanting to separate it. Yeah. And Greg was so gracious. Greg was like, Angela, oh my God, thank you so much for sharing that with me. It's totally not what I intended. We just wanted a heightened moment so that Oscar shoves past you so that we can sort of have this crescendo that makes Michael come out and say everyone to the conference room.
宗教信仰分开的。”而这正是你想做的事。你想要把它俩分开。是的。格里格人太好了。格里格说：“安吉拉，哦，天哪，非常感谢你跟我分享这些。这完全不是我的本意。我们只是想要一个情绪高潮的时刻，让奥斯卡从你身边挤过去，这样我们才能有一个层层递进的高潮，促使迈克尔走出来说：‘所有人去会议室。’”
So he was like, yeah, we'll come up with a different line. And thank you so much for sharing that with me. So I felt like relief. And I also felt like my mom could watch the episode without getting upset, too upset. I was like, oh, no. All right, mom. Yes. She's still snarky.
所以他当时说：“好吧，我们会想出一句不同的台词。非常感谢你跟我分享这些。”所以我感到如释重负。我也觉得我妈妈看这一集时不会感到心烦意乱、不会太生气。我当时想：哦，太好了，妈妈。是的。她还是很刻薄。
She's still really mean and snarky. But yeah, I was really appreciative to Greg for hearing me out. So Michael has now had it. Like he's like, okay, everyone, I don't care who you are or what's going on with you. Get in the conference room. We're going to talk this out. Yes. And I think this is a good place for a break.
她依然非常刻薄。但是，是的，我非常感谢格里格能听取我的意见。所以迈克尔现在受够了。他就像是：好吧，各位，不管你是谁或者你身上发生了什么。都给我进会议室。我们要把这事谈清楚。是的。我觉得这里很适合暂停休息一下。
As everyone walks into the conference room, we will take a break and we will come back with everything that happens in the conference room, which is a lot. All right, so we're back. We're in the conference room. Michael is leading a discussion about what it means to be gay. This includes one of my favorite lines from this episode, which is yours, Angela, when Michael asks, who should be the judges and juries of our society? The judges and the juries. And he says, you're making a good point. I mean, I love that. This conference room scene has some great cutaways as well.
当大家走进会议室时，我们将休息一下，然后回来继续看会议室里发生的一切，那可真是一团糟。好了，我们回来了。我们在会议室里。迈克尔正在主持一场关于“身为同性恋意味着什么”的讨论。这其中包括了本集中我最喜欢的一句台词，也就是你的台词，安吉拉。当迈克尔问：“谁应该是我们社会的法官和陪审团？”法官和陪审团。而他说：“你这话切中要害。”我的意思是，我太喜欢这个了。这个会议室的场景也有一些很棒的切眼镜头。
And it is Creed's, one of his favorite talking heads happens. Yes. He's done it for us live in studio. In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors in the rain and the mud. It's possible a man slipped in. There'd be no way of knowing. Yes. No way of knowing. No way of knowing. So this is one of Creed's favorite talking heads. I love it. We also learned, oh my gosh, we learned that Phyllis is engaged. Yes. Phyllis, this is when it's revealed that Phyllis is engaged because Dwight says Phyllis might be a lesbian.
这也是克里德最喜欢的访谈镜头之一。是的。他在录音室里给我们现场表演过。在60年代，我和许许多多女性做过爱，经常在户外、在雨中、在泥地里。很可能有某个男人也滑进来了。根本无从知晓。是的。无从知晓。无从知晓。所以这是克里德最喜欢的访谈镜头之一。我超爱。我们还得知，哦，天哪，我们得知菲利斯订婚了。是的。菲利斯，就是在这个时候大家发现菲利斯订婚了，因为德怀特说菲利斯可能是个女同性恋。
And she's like, actually, I'm getting married to Bob Vance. And we're all like, we're all very excited. She didn't announce it or tell us. This is how we all find out. Then she shows her ring off. Right. And we're looking over. Jenna, is Phyllis's ring a cluster ring? Angela,
而她说：“其实，我要和鲍勃·范斯结婚了。”然后我们所有人都——我们都超级兴奋。她之前根本没宣布也没告诉我们。这就是我们大家发现的方式。然后她炫耀起她的戒指。没错。我们在看着那边。珍娜，菲利斯的戒指是一个群镶钻戒吗？安吉拉，
I think it's a cluster. What? And Bob Vance. Bob Vance should get her a big rock. I don't believe it. I don't believe it. And I think you're going to see in later episodes, it gets switched. I think it does. I remember her having a big honking ring and we're like, oh, Bob Vance. Huh? And like we did, we did bits about it. But in this shot, it looked like a cluster ring. It's a cluster. I mean, Bob Vance is a very showy guy.
我觉得那是一团碎钻。什么？还有鲍勃·万斯。鲍勃·万斯应该给她买个大钻戒。我不信。我真不信。而且我觉得在后面的剧集中你会发现，戒指换了。我觉得是的。我记得她戴着一个很大的戒指，我们当时就想，哦，鲍勃·万斯。啊？就像我们那样，我们还拿这个开过玩笑。但在这组镜头里，它看起来像个群镶钻戒。是一团碎钻。我是说，鲍勃·万斯是个很爱显摆的人。
He's going to give his lady a big old solitaire. Yes, he is. Yes, he is. OK, we need to track that. And Phyllis has, you know, a line in here that I love because I love every single time Phyllis reminds us all that she and Michael went to high school together. I live for it. I live for it.
他肯定会给他的女人买一颗超大的单粒美钻。是的，他会的。是的，他会的。好吧，我们需要追踪一下这个。菲莉丝在这里面有一句台词我非常喜欢，因为我太喜欢菲莉丝每次提醒大家她和迈克尔是高中同学了。我活着就是为了这个。我太爱了。
You know, Angela, that one got me curious because I was like, I don't think that Phyllis and Steve are the same age. I actually went to Wikipedia and I looked it up and there is a 10 year age difference between Steve Carell and Phyllis Smith in real life. But nonetheless, I love this runner. It's a very funny runner and Michael hates it. But we also learned that Michael in high school wore suits and ties and matching fancy socks and fancy socks. I love that backstory. Yeah. There's also a moment in the conference room where Michael says, we're all homos, homo sapiens. And Pam, this is, this makes Pam laugh and she giggles and turns to the person next to her, but it's Ryan. And Ryan gives you nothing. No, nothing. And you'll notice in this episode, when we cut
你知道吗，安吉拉，那句台词让我很好奇，因为我想，我觉得菲莉丝和史蒂夫不是同龄人。我甚至去维基百科查了一下，现实生活中史蒂夫·卡瑞尔和菲莉丝·史密斯相差10岁。但尽管如此，我还是很喜欢这个小插曲。这是一个非常搞笑的小插曲，迈克尔讨厌它。但我们也了解到，迈克尔在高中时穿西装打领带，还穿相配的花哨袜子和花哨的袜子。我喜欢这个背景故事。是的。会议室里还有一个时刻，迈克尔说，我们都是同性恋（homos），智人（homo sapiens）。而潘，这个，这让潘笑了，她咯咯笑着转向旁边的人，但那是瑞恩。而瑞恩一点反应也没有。不，什么都没有。你会注意到这一集中，当我们切
back to Jim in the conference room at Stanford, he is having memories of conference rooms with Pam, just like Pam is having her memories of conference rooms with Jim. And they have no one to look at to sort of share the experience with. I know. Their person is gone. Yeah, their person is gone. So then Michael goes on this tangent. He just says, you know, gay marriage isn't legal. And how many straight men wished that applied to them? He's like, you're so lucky, Oscar, that gay marriage isn't legal. I feel like I've seen this like in sort of a stand up routine. I feel like this concept.
回到斯坦福会议室里的吉姆时，他正在回忆和潘在会议室里的情景，就像潘在回忆和吉姆在会议室里的情景一样。他们身边没有可以分享这种经历的人了。我知道。他们专属的那个人不在了。是的，他们专属的那个人不在了。然后迈克尔开始扯远了。他说，你知道，同性婚姻是不合法的。有多少直男希望这条法律也适用于他们呢？他说，奥斯卡，你太幸运了，同性婚姻是不合法的。我觉得我好像在某种脱口秀表演里见过这个。我觉得这个概念……
Yeah, I feel like Michael has like pulled some of his comedians that he's seen sort of do this bit that I bet husbands out there wish that. I feel like Michael is doing his bit. I think you're so right on that. Here's the thing. When I heard that, I actually thought to myself, oh my God, gay marriage wasn't legal. Like it is legal now, right? But yes, we shot this back in 2007. And gay marriage was not legal.
对，我觉得迈克尔可能是从他看过的某些喜剧演员那里听来了这个段子，我敢打赌外面的丈夫们也会希望……我觉得迈克尔在表演他的段子。我觉得你说得太对了。事情是这样的。当我听到那句话时，我甚至心里想，天哪，同性婚姻是不合法的。就像现在它合法了一样，对吧？但是是的，我们是在2007年拍摄的这一集。当时同性婚姻确实不合法。
Angela, this sent me on a tangent. Where did you go? Where did you go? Angela, I went on a deep dive. Uh-oh. Sam, can I get a deep dive, please? Did you hear that, Angela? I did.
安吉拉，这让我开始发散思维了。你去哪了？你去哪了？安吉拉，我深入研究了一下。哦，不。山姆，能给我来一段“深入研究”的音效吗？你听到了吗，安吉拉？听到了。
It sounded like a toilet being flushed. Oh, dear. Okay. No, that's me doing a deep dive into the history of gay marriage. Wait one second.
听起来像是在冲马桶。哦，天哪。好吧。不，那是我在深入研究同性婚姻的历史。等一下。
Do you and Sam trade emails about sound effects? Because I feel like you have some shorthand with Sam that I don't have where I'm not like,
你和山姆会互相发关于音效的电子邮件吗？因为我觉得你和山姆之间有一些我没有的默契，我不会像这样说：
Sam, hit the full Mindy. Sam, give me a bird going, caw, caw. Sam, give me a beer, like sound. Maybe we do, and maybe we do. Maybe Sam and I trade sound effects emails from time to time. If you want to know, I also recorded this. You got a deep, you got a dive. You put them together, get a deep dive. Are those your children? That's my son. He made me a deep dive sting.
山姆，来个全套的明迪。山姆，给我一只鸟叫声，嘎，嘎。山姆，给我来个啤酒倒酒的声音。也许我们真的会，也许吧。也许我和山姆时不时会交流一些音效邮件。如果你想知道的话，我还录了这个。你得到了一个“深入”（deep），你得到了一个“研究”（dive）。你把它们拼在一起，就成了“深入研究”（deep dive）。那是你的孩子吗？那是我的儿子。他给我制作了一段“深入研究”的转场音效。
I like that. I might like that better than your toilet flush. Well, listen, the point is I did a deep dive on the history of gay marriage, and I'm going to throw it at you. Are you ready? Okay, I guess throw it at me. All right. So in the year 2000, 20 years ago, Vermont was the first place in the country of the United States to allow civil unions for gay couples. The first state to legalize gay marriage was Massachusetts in 2003.
我喜欢那个。我可能比你那个冲马桶的声音更喜欢它。好吧，听着，重点是我对同性婚姻的历史做了一番深入研究，我要把它抛给你。准备好了吗？好吧，我想你可以抛给我了。好的。那么在2000年，也就是20年前，佛蒙特州是美国第一个允许同性伴侣进行民事结合的地方。第一个将同性婚姻合法化的州是2003年的马萨诸塞州。
Look at you. Look at you, mess. Look at you go. Look at them go. Did I do a good one? Was that good? Look at them go. I don't know, honey.
看看你。看看你，这团乱麻。看你多厉害。看他们多厉害。我表现得好吗？刚才那个好吗？看他们多厉害。我不知道，亲爱的。
I don't know what that was. They were so smart in Massachusetts. They're so super smart. All right. So go on. Wicked smart. They're wicked smart. Wicked smart. Way to go.
我不知道刚才那是什么。马萨诸塞州的人太聪明了。他们超级聪明。好吧。所以继续。聪明绝顶。他们聪明绝顶。聪明绝顶。干得好。
All right. All right. So Massachusetts was the first state smart. Wicked smart. Way to go. All right. All right. So Massachusetts was the first state to legalize gay marriage. Pennsylvania was the last state in the northeastern region to recognize same sex marriage. It did not become legal there until a state Supreme Court ruling in May of 2014. And it did not become legal in all 50 United States until June 26th, 2015. There was a Supreme Court ruling. That decision struck down bans on same-sex marriage, legalized it in all 50 states, and
好吧。好吧。所以马萨诸塞州是第一个……聪明绝顶。聪明绝顶。干得好。好吧。好吧。所以马萨诸塞州是第一个将同性婚姻合法化的州。宾夕法尼亚州是东北地区最后一个承认同性婚姻的州。直到2014年5月州最高法院做出裁决，同性婚姻在那里才变得合法。直到2015年6月26日，同性婚姻才在全美50个州全部合法。当时最高法院做出了一项裁决。该裁决推翻了对同性婚姻的禁令，使其在所有50个州合法化，并
said that all states had to honor out-of-state marriage licenses. Lady, that was only five years ago? That is astonishing to me. Anyway, that was my deep dive, guys. I got super curious when I heard him say that. Yeah. Because now it is the law, but there was a time when it was not, and I wanted to learn more about it. So there you have it. There you have it. She's here for the deep dives on your alpha womb. And yes, here are the things i've deep dived so far can you get yams at a gas station in carbondale you really deep dived on that what is an alpha womb yeah you
且规定所有州都必须承认外州颁发的结婚证。天哪，那竟然只是五年前的事吗？这让我大吃一惊。不管怎样，这就是我的深入研究，伙计们。当我听到他说那句话时，我真的超级好奇。是的。因为现在这是法律了，但曾经有一段时间不是这样的，我想多了解一下。所以就是这样。就是这样。她是为了你那个“阿尔法子宫”的深入研究而来的。是的，这是我到目前为止深入研究过的事情：你能在卡本代尔的加油站买到山药吗？你真的对这个进行了深入研究。什么是阿尔法子宫？对，
gay marriage and now well don't forget you did stock a college acapella group and you know their rehearsal schedule so let's let's try oh my. I did two deep dives in this episode. I'm really contributing. I'm contributing. Okay. So guys, this conference room meeting is not going well. Oscar says to Toby, I don't even think I can work here anymore. This is the worst day of my life. He gets up to leave and Michael stops him. And now we are going to have the most glorious interaction. So we could not talk about the awkwardly cringy awesomeness of this scene without Oscar Nunez. So y'all, we called him. Yeah, we did.
同性婚姻，还有……好吧，别忘了你还跟踪了一个大学无伴奏合唱团，你知道他们的排练时间表，所以让我们……让我们试试，噢，天哪。我在这一集里做了两次深入研究。我真的很有贡献。我在做贡献。好吧。所以伙计们，这次会议室会议很不顺利。奥斯卡对托比说，我觉得我甚至不能在这里工作了。这是我一生中最糟糕的一天。他起身要走，迈克尔拦住了他。现在我们将迎来最精彩的一幕。所以，如果没有奥斯卡·努涅斯，我们就无法谈论这个场景中那种尴尬到脚趾扣地的精彩。所以大家，我们给他打电话了。是的，我们打了。
We recorded it. And here it is. Hi, Oscar. Hi, Jenna. Hi, Oscar. Woo-hoo! Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela. Oh, this is so fun, Oscar. You know what this is, Jenna?
我们录下来了。这就是。嗨，奥斯卡。嗨，珍娜。嗨，奥斯卡。呜呼！嗨，珍娜。嗨，安吉拉。哦，太有趣了，奥斯卡。你知道这是什么吗，珍娜？
What? It's un-be-lie-vable! Yes! It is unbelievable. That's what I do all, when I want to get a laugh i watch the office but i watch the bloopers i go through all the seasons and that's one of the takes that makes me laugh so much i love that you know isabel loves the bloopers i mean too i love the bloopers i just remember we could not get through that scene no fisher you were the instigator you couldn't get it together
什么？太——不可思议了！对！这太不可思议了。这就是我每次想笑的时候所做的，当我想笑的时候，我就看《办公室》，但我看的是片场花絮，我把所有季都看了一遍，那是最让我捧腹大笑的镜头之一，我太喜欢了，你知道伊莎贝尔很喜欢花絮，我也是，我超爱花絮，我只记得我们当时根本无法拍完那一幕，诺·费舍尔，你就是那个罪魁祸首，你们根本控制不住自己。
I know I'm sorry I'm sorry you guys are funny it happens and also we never ever got to do talking heads together so it was just like the novelty of that too yeah it was funny it was so good Oscar you never break you never break you know I I was watching, I think it's season four, Ed Helms made me crack up. Because he just, he mugs so much, his funny faces. And it's still grounded. And Ed Helms made me crack up in one of the bloopers. But truly, I feel like we could count on one hand the number of times you broke in the whole nine seasons. In nine years.
我知道，对不起，对不起，你们太搞笑了，这种事难免发生。而且，我们以前从来没有一起拍过“谈话头”（talking heads）镜头，所以那种新鲜感也……对，太搞笑了，真的太棒了。奥斯卡，你从不笑场，你从来都不笑场，你知道吗，我当时在看，好像是第四季，埃德·赫尔姆斯把我逗笑了。因为他做出的鬼脸太多了，各种好笑的表情。而且依然很接地气。埃德·赫尔姆斯在一个花絮里把我逗笑了。但说实话，我觉得在整整九季里，你笑场的次数屈指可数。在九年里。
My nickname for Oscar was the statue. Because you broke in the whole nine years in nine years my nickname for oscar was the statue because you never broke yeah well oscar it's a good thing that you were steve's scene partner in gay witch hunt everybody else in the room broke you did not and thank goodness because then they had usable takes because j Jenna, I stifled it. I know your tells because I sat back with you in accounting. So Brian did the tea kettle. We've talked about that, how he, as he would start to laugh, he would like try to hide it by blowing out the corner of his mouth. I called it the tea kettle.
我给奥斯卡起的外号叫“雕像”。因为在整整九季里你从来没笑场过，在整整九年里，我给奥斯卡起的外号叫“雕像”，因为你从不笑场。好吧，奥斯卡，你在《同性恋搜捕》里能成为史蒂夫的对手戏演员真是太好了，房间里的其他人都笑场了谢天谢地你没有笑，谢天谢地，因为这样他们才有可用的镜头，因为珍娜，我强忍着。我知道你的小动作，因为我以前和你在会计部坐在一起。所以布莱恩当时发出了茶壶的声音。我们讨论过这个，当他开始笑的时候，他会试图通过鼓起嘴角来掩饰。我把它叫做“茶壶”。
He'd be like, yes, yes, like that. That's right. But you did this tiny, minuscule, like a grunt. But no one knew you would, like a grunt. But no one knew. You would go like a, like that. So now I need to go back and watch that scene. We'll get to it, but I want to see if I can hear it.
他会发出那种声音，是的，是的，就像那样。没错。但你会发出一种极其微小的声音，就像咕哝声一样。但没有人知道你会，就像咕哝声一样。但没人知道。你会发出那种，类似那样的声音。所以现在我得回去重温那个镜头了。我们待会儿会说到，但我想看看我能不能听到它。
Okay, but before we get into the scene, Oscar, we start, whenever we have a guest on the show, we ask them a little bit about how you came to be on The Office. Like, what was your audition process? Like, what's your story? Well, okay, I'll just start with the audition, because I don't want to, because you and I knew each other from before, and I don't even know when, The Groundlings or something, where we met. The Groundlings, Oscar. Okay, Oscar and I had known each other forever, but Jenna, like how you were talking about with John, like this was before you texted people or knew information about what was going on in their lives. There was no social media. So I had no idea that Oscar auditioned and he didn't know that I auditioned. And I didn't know that he got it until the day I walked on set the first day. And I walk over to accounting where they told me I was sitting and there's Oscar. And I'm like, oh my God, it's like, it's like a, like a movie, like a Harry met Sally or
好的，但在我们进入那个场景之前，奥斯卡，我们每次有嘉宾上节目时，都会问他们一些关于你是如何加入《办公室》的故事。比如，你的试镜过程是怎样的？你的故事是什么？好吧，好吧，我就从试镜开始讲起吧，因为我不想……因为你和我以前就认识，我甚至不记得是什么时候了，是在嬉剧团（The Groundlings）还是什么地方，我们见面的。嬉剧团，奥斯卡。好吧，我和奥斯卡认识很久了，但是珍娜，就像你之前说约翰的那样，这发生在你给别人发短信或了解他们生活动态之前。当时还没有社交媒体。所以我完全不知道奥斯卡去试镜了，他也不知道我去试镜了。直到我第一天走进片场的那天，我才知道他被选上了。我走到他们告诉我座位的会计部，然后奥斯卡就在那里。我当时想，天哪，这感觉就像，就像一部电影，就像《当哈利遇到莎莉》或者
something. We did not know this, not through gossip, not through reading paperwork. We both walked on the set and there we were in wardrobe. And I'm like, what are you doing here? And she's like, what are you doing here? I'm like, oh no, we're on the same show. We were so excited because we had done a sketch comedy show we had met god oscar what like 15 years earlier it's such a great feeling to see a friend and you're like we're on the same show that really happens but it does happen but not just on the same show You guys were like teammates. We were in the same department, you know? So even better. And speaking of that, Oscar, did you audition for the role of an accountant? Yes, they needed extra people. They gave me copy to read and it was a general office stuff. Okay. And my manager, Bruce is like, it's for the office. And I'm like, well, that sounds good.
什么的。我们事先并不知道，不是通过八卦，也不是通过看文件。我们两个都走进了片场，然后我们就穿着戏服站在那里。我说，你在这里干什么？她说，你在这里干什么？我说，哦，不，我们在同一个节目里。我们当时超级兴奋，因为我们以前演过一个小品喜剧节目，我们认识，天哪，奥斯卡，大概是15年前吧？看到一个朋友，然后说我们在同一个节目里，这种感觉太棒了，这种事真的很少发生，但确实发生了，而且不仅在同一个节目里。你们就像队友一样。我们在同一个部门，你知道吗？所以更好。说到这个，奥斯卡，你当时是为会计的角色去试镜的吗？是的，他们需要额外的人。他们给我台词让我读，都是一些一般的办公室杂务。好吧。我的经纪人布鲁斯说，这是为《办公室》试镜的。我说，听起来不错。
And my manager, Bruce, is like, it's for the office. And I'm like, well, that sounds good. And I love the British office. But I thought, we'll do the pilot and it won't get picked up. That was my feeling. I was so skeptical. I think we all felt that way. I was so over it. But I love the show.
我的经纪人布鲁斯说，这是为《办公室》试镜的。我说，听起来不错。而且我很喜欢英国版的《办公室》。但我想，我们拍完试播集，然后这个节目就不会被续订了。我当时就是这么想的。我当时持严重怀疑态度。我想我们所有人当时都是这种感觉。我已经对它不抱太大希望了。但我很喜欢这个节目。
I love the Ricky Gervais. And I'm like, oh, it's great, but we're not going to do it justice. That's what I was like. We're not going to do justice. Don't get excited, Oscar. Don't get excited. And I think that's why I did well, because I didn't care. And then they're like, well, let's come in for a callback. And then the callback, I think it must have been
我很喜欢瑞奇·热维斯的作品。我觉得，哦，这很棒，但我们是拍不出那种神韵的。我当时就是这么想的。我们拍不出那种神韵。别太激动，奥斯卡。别太激动。我想这就是我当时表现得好的原因，因为我根本不在乎。然后他们说，好吧，来参加复试吧。复试的时候，那肯定是有
scripted, but I went in, I think three times or maybe four, three for sure. And then the last one was improv. And I was like, okay, I really like this because I can improv. Because I was literally in the groundlings of it. So I improvised the live long day. And I had a really good time and tried to keep it close to the vest and not go too crazy. And then my manager called and said, you got it. And I got a little bit more excited, but still did not quit my day job. I was catering and babysitting.
剧本的，但我去了，我想是去了三次或者四次，三次肯定是有的。最后一次是即兴表演。当时我想，好吧，我真的很喜欢这个，因为我很会即兴发挥。因为我当时实实在在地在嬉剧团。所以我从早到晚都在即兴发挥。我玩得很开心，尽量把表现控制在合理范围内，没有太疯狂。然后我的经纪人打电话说，你被选中了。我当时稍微激动了一点点，但还是没有辞掉我的全职工作。我当时还在做餐饮外包和临时保姆。
And did not quit until we got picked up for the season. And then Flannery and I quit at the same time. We looked at each other. We're like, now, she's like, now, yeah, let's do it now. I'm like, all right, let's do it. And we both quit. We're like, you quit catering, catering and babysitting and Kate quit being a waitress. That's right. And her lovely manager said, everyone wished her well. And her manager said, you'll be back. She's like, oh, thank you for that. All right. Let's talk about this scene. All right, Oscar.
直到我们被正式续订了一整季，我才辞职。然后凯特·弗兰纳里和我同时辞职了。我们看着彼此。我们说，现在吗？她说，现在，对，我们现在就辞。我说，好吧，那就辞。于是我们两个都辞职了。我们想，你辞掉了餐饮外包和保姆的工作，凯特辞掉了女服务员的工作。没错。她那位可爱的经纪人说，每个人都祝她一切顺利。而她的经纪人说，你会回来的。她当时想，哦，谢谢你这么说。好吧。我们来谈谈这个场景吧。好吧，奥斯卡。
This is the scene where Michael starts by offering to hug you. You know, you're upset. You're like, I'm out of here. And Michael's like, come on, I'm going to give you a hug in an attempt to show that he's totally OK with Oscar being gay. But this ended up with Steve kissing you on the lips, which was not scripted. Well, it's crazy because Michael like completely offends you and you're like, you feel insulted. You want to leave.
这是迈克尔一开始提出要拥抱你的那个场景。你知道的，你当时很不高兴。你当时说，我要离开这里。然后迈克尔说，来吧，我要给你一个拥抱，以此来表明他完全不介意奥斯卡是同性恋。但最后的结果却是史蒂夫吻了你的嘴唇，而这并不是剧本里写好的。好吧，这太疯狂了，因为迈克尔完全把你冒犯了，你当时觉得受到了侮辱。你想离开。
Then, then you realize you've broken Michael's heart. And so you're like, okay, buddy, come here. Now you're, you're comforting Michael and he's like tearing up. It's just like, none of this should be happening in a workplace. Becoming his parent in the moment. None of this should be happening in a workplace. No. Well, Oscar, I have the script from Gay Witch Hunt, and I looked it up, and here is what was originally scripted. Because I was curious, because I knew that what ended up airing was an improv. So originally, he hugs you, and then he was supposed to go in for a kiss, but he chickens out and is supposed to like kiss you on the forehead or something.
然后，然后你意识到你伤了迈克尔的心。于是你说，好吧，伙计，过来吧。现在变成你在安慰迈克尔了，他甚至都快哭了。这感觉就像，这些事根本不应该发生在职场中。那一刻你成了他的家长。这些事根本不应该发生在职场中。没错。好吧，奥斯卡，我有《同性恋搜捕》的剧本，我查了一下，原本的剧本是这样的。因为我很好奇，我知道最终播出的版本是即兴发挥的。所以原本的剧本是，他拥抱了你，然后他本该凑过去亲吻你，但他临阵退缩了，本该亲你的额头什么的。
But I remember sitting in that room and when Steve said the line, I want you to burn this into your brains. That was the moment. We knew that was improv. Yeah, that was an improv line. What does Steve have in his head right now? And Oscar, to me as an audience member, and I'm saying audience member, like, because I was, I was just sitting in the conference room as an audience member. That line was the moment when I knew we had taken a turn on to a totally new road. What was it for you?
但我记得当时坐在那个房间里，当史蒂夫说出那句台词：“我希望你们把这个永远铭刻在脑海里。”就是那一刻。我们知道那是即兴发挥。是的，那是一句即兴台词。史蒂夫当时脑子里在想什么？奥斯卡，对我来说，作为一个观众，我之所以说观众，是因为我当时就坐在会议室里当观众。那句台词就是我意识到我们已经驶上一条全新道路的时刻。对你来说呢？
Do you remember, like, when you were like, wait, what's going on? Well, I've had time to process it. But at the moment, I think we did three or four takes. Not a lot with hugging, with the way you're saying, with the hugging. And then this particular take, he's coming in and I'm like, oh, he's going to, he really caught me off guard. He's coming in closer and closer and his nose is getting closer to my nose. And I'm thinking, I'm thinking, well, I don't know what's happening. So I'm just going to stand here because he's going to hug me.
你还记得你当时是什么时候想“等等，这到底是怎么回事”的吗？好吧，我有时间来消化它。但在当时，我想我们大概拍了三四条。拥抱的镜头并不多，就像你说的，就是那种拥抱。然后在这一条里，他凑过来，我当时想，哦，他要……他真的把我弄得措手不及。他越凑越近，他的鼻子离我的鼻子越来越近。我心想，我心想，好吧，我不知道现在是什么情况。所以我决定就站在这儿，因为他要拥抱我。
And I'm thinking, pick a side. You know, when you hug someone, Jenna, you have to go left or right. Yeah. And I'm like, pick a side, pick a side, pick a side. And I to go left or right yeah i'm like pick a side pick a side pick a side and i'm like oh no he's not picking a side he's because i'm like i'm like he's not picking a side and then he came in for a sweet sweet kiss and our lips touched and then that's when like this laugh came from my stomach and i stopped it and i also heard a lot of giggling and snickering from the peanut gallery and i I'm like, oh, I hope the cameras.
我当时在想，选一边。你知道的，当你拥抱某人时，珍娜，你必须向左或向右倾斜。是的。我当时想，选一边，选一边，选一边。我必须向左或向右倾斜，是的，我心想，选一边，选一边，选一边，然后我想，哦，不，他没有选一边，因为我心想，我心想，他没有选一边，然后他凑过来，给了我一个甜蜜的吻，我们的嘴唇碰在了一起，然后我的胃里就涌起一阵笑意，我把它给憋回去了。我还听到后排围观群众发出了很多咯咯的笑声和窃笑声，我当时想，哦，希望摄像机……
Well, it doesn't matter because that's the reaction. Whatever's happening is happening. And they stopped kissing me. And I'm like, okay, stay in character. And I'm like, I said, thank you. I think. I don't know why. Well, he has this great line.
好吧，这无所谓，因为这就是当时的真实反应。不管发生了什么，反正发生了。然后他们停止了亲吻。我心想，好吧，保持角色状态。然后我说，谢谢你。我想是的。我不知道为什么。好吧，他有一句非常棒的台词。
He has this great line where, well, first of all, you improvised a great line oscar where you're like we don't have to do this and he's like yes we do yes we do and then after he improvised this line where he was like there i get it like it's he's the hero and we're still here we're still here i know he's the hero he did it he did it he dragged me out of the closet where i was perfectly happy well the thing that amazes me is that when you see all of our reactions we were just reacting in real time i know and yet we also are seem to be reacting in character except for bj i'll tell you bj turns away in that moment when he's sitting next to me because he started laughing. The reason he turned away was because he lost it. He lost it.
他有一句非常棒的台词，好吧，首先，奥斯卡，你即兴发挥了一句很棒的台词，你说我们不必这样做，而他说，不，我们必须这样做，是的，必须这样做。然后在他即兴说出那句台词之后，他说，看，我懂了，就像他是英雄一样，而我们还在这里，我们还在这里，我知道他是英雄，他做到了，他做到了，他把我从壁橱里拉了出来，而我原本在里面待得好好的。好吧，最让我惊叹的是，当你看到我们所有人的反应时，我们只是在实时做出反应。我知道，然而我们看起来也完全是在角色状态中，除了B.J.。我跟你说，B.J.在那一刻转过身去了，当他坐在我旁边的时候，因为他开始笑了。他转过身去的原因是他彻底笑崩了。他笑崩了。
And then the camera cut so you can't see it. Carell's insane. I covered my face because I was laughing. And I thought, okay, hopefully this tracks that Angela Martin wouldn't want to see it because I'm laughing and I don't want to ruin this moment. Oh my God. The closest to us or one of the closest. She was like right there.
然后镜头切走了，所以你看不到。卡尔疯了。我用手捂住脸，因为我在笑。我心想，好吧，希望这符合逻辑，安吉拉·马丁肯定不想看到这一幕，因为我在笑，而我不想毁了这个时刻。天哪。离我们最近的人之一。她当时就坐在那儿。
Well, Oscar, I don't know if you remember, but you and I were doing an interview together. Oh my gosh. I don't know where we were. We were doing a press junket for NBC and someone asked you about the moment and I'll never forget because I remember, I remember it because you cursed and I was like, I know we're on camera, but you said something like, then all of a sudden Steve keeps coming closer. And I'm like, son of a bitch, he's going to kiss me. You had this moment where you knew it was past the point of no return. It's happening. Well, Steve was amazing because when he would come up with those improvs on set, I feel like I have a lot of memories and this is the one that is like most prevalent, but just the memory of him, you see him get an idea, but then he is a master at slow playing the idea.
好吧，奥斯卡，我不知道你是否还记得，你和我以前一起做过一次采访。哦，天哪。我不知道我们在哪。我们在为NBC做一个记者招待会，有人问起你关于那个时刻的事，我永远不会忘记，因为我记得，我记得是因为你说粗口了，我当时心想，我知道我们在镜头前，但你说了一句类似“然后突然史蒂夫越凑越近，我心想，他妈的，他要亲我了”。你当时经历了那个时刻，你知道已经无法回头了，事情正在发生。好吧，史蒂夫太棒了，因为当他在片场想出那些即兴台词时，我觉得我有很多记忆，而这是最深刻的一个，就是关于他的记忆，你看到他有了一个想法，但他擅长把这个想法慢条斯理地表现出来。
I saw him, as soon as he said, I want you to burn this into your brains, I knew, oh my gosh, he has an idea. But he made me wait for it. And he made all of us wait for it. And that is the genius of his comic timing. All of us wait for it. And that is the genius of his comic timing. For Michael Scott, even though it's ass backwards, it was a very brave thing of him to, in his mind,
我看到他一说出“我希望你们把这个永远铭刻在脑海里”，我就知道，哦，天哪，他有了一个想法。但他让我等。他让在场的我们所有人都等。这就是他喜剧时效性的天才之处。让在场的我们所有人都等。这就是他喜剧时效性的天才之处。对于迈克尔·斯科特来说，尽管这完全是本末倒置，但在他心里，这绝对是一件非常勇敢的事。
Michael Scott, he's like, he was the hero, right? He's like, look what I did. Look what I did. No one else could have done this. That's why I have the mug. World's best boss. Look what I did. And then Jenna, I have the mug. World's best boss. Look what I did. And then Jenna, I have a,
迈克尔·斯科特，他觉得自己就像个英雄，对吧？他就像在说，看我做了什么！看我做了什么！其他人绝对做不到这一点。这就是为什么我有这个马克杯。世界上最棒的老板。看我做了什么。然后珍娜，我有这个马克杯。世界上最棒的老板。看我做了什么。然后珍娜，我有一个，
I have a question because I am pretty sure I remember this correctly, but you have the script when rain as Dwight then chimes in to kiss him. Rain improvised that. Oh yeah. That was totally improvised. And I just love that. That's the button that's like, I'm going to get in there. That's his MO. That's apropos. He did that aight's like, I'm going to get in here. That's his M.O. That's apropos.
我有一个问题，因为我确信我没记错，但当雷恩饰演的德怀特随后插话也要去亲他时，剧本里有吗？雷恩那是即兴发挥的。哦，是的。那是完全即兴的。我太喜欢那个了。那是神来之笔，就像是在说“我也要加入”。那是他的惯用伎俩。太贴切了。他经常那样做。他也想加入。那是他的惯常做法。太贴切了。
He did that a lot. He just didn't do it in that scene. Michael would do something and then he would get inspired and go, I'm going to do what my boss is doing. Yeah. But Michael said, no, no, Dwight, Dwight, don't. Yeah. Because he needed it. It was just for him.
他经常那样做。只是他没有在那个场景里这样做。迈克尔会做一些事情，然后他就会受到启发，心想：“我的老板在做什么，我也要跟着做什么。”是的。但迈克尔说：“不，不，德怀特，德怀特，别这样。”是的。因为他需要那种感觉。那是专属于他的。
You can see Rain break a little bit there. After he tries to kiss you you see yeah a little bit of a smile i tip my hat to all you guys because that was a ridiculous moment and for him to pull back and say we did it we're still here we're still we did it everyone dragging everyone in with him to this thing i wrote it 18 minutes uh 56 seconds i wrote, I think Oscar's about to break right here. That's the moment I caught. So I'm going to go back and see if it's your weird stomach grunt moment. That was probably the most documentary moment of our fake documentary.
你能看到雷恩在那里稍微笑场了一点。在他试图亲你之后，你能看到……是的，有一点点微笑。我向你们所有人脱帽致敬，因为那是一个荒谬至极的时刻，而他能够收回来并说：“我们做到了，我们还在这里，我们做到了”，把每个人都拉进他搞出来的这件事里。我记下了，18分56秒，我记下了，我觉得奥斯卡在这里快要笑场了。这就是我捕捉到的那一刻。所以我要回去看看那是不是你那个奇怪的胃部咕哝声时刻。那可能是我们伪纪录片中最具纪录片风格的一个时刻。
That and when we sang goodbye to Steve. Oh my gosh. Because remember, Steve didn't know. No. Okay, Oscar, before you go, I want to ask you this fan question. So as a result of Michael's behavior, Oscar ends up accepting a settlement with corporate and it includes this three month paid leave. And he says he and Gil are going to go to Europe. So Melinda Magerkirth and Mike McCarthy wrote in to ask this.
还有我们向史蒂夫唱再见歌的时候。哦，天哪。因为记得吗，史蒂夫事先并不知道。没错。好吧，奥斯卡，在你离开之前，我想问你一个粉丝提问。由于迈克尔的行为，奥斯卡最终接受了公司的一笔赔偿金，其中包含三个月的带薪休假。他说他和吉尔要去欧洲。所以梅琳达·马格库斯和迈克·麦卡锡写信来问了这样一个问题。
Niagara Kurth and Mike McCarthy wrote in to ask this. When the character of Oscar goes on his three-month sabbatical, what was the real Oscar up to in real life during those three months? This comes under the umbrella of having two wonderful mentions as your bosses. I, when it rains, it pours, you guys. And while I was on The Office, I pitched a show at Comedy Central, and they said yes. It was an improvised show, which the aforementioned Damon Jones, Damon Jones, who was in the running for being the lead, is my buddy,
尼亚拉·库尔斯和迈克·麦卡锡写信来问了这样一个问题。当奥斯卡这个角色去度他那三个月的休假时，现实生活中的真实奥斯卡在那三个月里在忙些什么？这其实得益于你作为老板的两次绝佳提拔。真的是祸不单行啊，伙计们。当我在拍《办公室》时，我在喜剧中心频道（Comedy Central）推销了一个节目，他们同意了。那是一个即兴喜剧节目，前面提到的达蒙·琼斯——达蒙·琼斯曾是主演的候选人之一，他是我的好朋友，
and he was executive producer of the show. We created it together, and this other fellow, Kevin Ruff, we sold the show to Comedy Central, and they said we wanted to do a season of it. And I'm like, oh, well, okay, but I'm on the office, but whatever, we'll figure it out. One day I was walking across, just to give you a little more glimpse into Steve and his thinking, he was walking across the, where our outside on the asphalt, where all the cars are parked, the parking lot, it's called Oscar, the parking lot. And all our trailers are there. And I caught up to him like, Steve, hey, what's up?
他是那个节目的执行制片人。我们一起创作了它，还有另一个家伙，凯文·鲁夫，我们把这个节目卖给了喜剧中心，他们说想要做一整季。我当时想，哦，好吧，但我正在拍《办公室》，不过管他呢，我们会想办法的。有一天我走在路上，为了让你对史蒂夫和他的思维方式有更多了解，他当时正走在……我们外面的沥青地上，所有汽车停放的地方，也就是停车场，停车场，奥斯卡。我们的房车都在那里。我追上他说：“史蒂夫，嘿，最近怎么样？”
I said, Steve, I was just offered to do a show at Comedy Central, but I love it here. What should I do? And he goes, Oscar, say yes to everything. Let your people figure it out. Let your manager and agent figure it out. That's not your job. You say yes to everything that they offer you. Don't worry about anything else. Say yes, people will figure it out. So I said yes. And I told Greg Daniels,
我说：“史蒂夫，我刚刚接到邀请去喜剧中心频道做一个节目，但我很喜欢这里。我该怎么办？”他说：“奥斯卡，对一切都说‘好’。让你的人去想办法。让你的经纪人和代理人去想办法。这不是你的工作。别人提供给你的一切，你都要说‘好’。不要担心其他任何事情。说‘好’，大家会想办法解决的。”所以我说“好”了。我把这事告诉了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，
and he's like, we'll figure it out. And they did. And this was my out. They gave me a beautiful, organic, seamless way out. So I was shooting a show. I was shooting 10 episodes of a show called Halfway Home. It was all improvised on Comedy Central. It was so good, Oscar. Thank you. It was so good. And so many of the people that we knew from the Groundlings and ImprovOlympic were part of it. And you know who else? Octavia Spencer.
他说：“我们会想办法解决的。”他们确实做到了。这就是我的退路。他们给了我一个美丽、自然且天衣无缝的退路。所以我当时在拍一个节目。我在拍一个叫《半途而废》（Halfway Home）的节目的10集。那是在喜剧中心频道播出的纯即兴节目。真的太棒了，奥斯卡。谢谢。真的很棒。而且我们在嬉剧团和即兴奥林匹克认识的许多人都参与其中。你猜还有谁？奥克塔维亚·斯派瑟。
How did she go on to do it? I think she did okay for herself. So Octavia was with us on that show. Many people went there. And Steve Pierce. Oh, so many people. Anyway, that's what I was doing. I went to do a show, uh, shot 10 episodes and then came back and,
她后来发展得怎么样？我想她现在发展得还不错吧。所以奥克塔维亚和我们一起拍了那个节目。很多人都去了。还有史蒂夫·皮尔斯。哦，好多人。不管怎样，我当时就是在做这个。我去拍了一个节目，拍了10集，然后又回来了，
and folded right back into the office because of Greg Daniels, because of, uh, Steve Carell and Silverman and all those people. But, you know, I think what people should know is that, that, that is very unique. I feel like to Greg, Greg was such a collaborator with us. And I know I had things throughout the nine-year run, and I know, Jenna, you did too, where we had to go to them and say, hey, we got this opportunity. Will we be able to make it work? And he was always pro making it work and figuring it out.
并且因为格雷格·丹尼尔斯，因为史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、西尔弗曼以及所有这些人的帮助，又顺利回到了《办公室》。但是，你知道，我认为人们应该知道的是，这非常独特。我觉得对格雷格来说，格雷格对我们非常包容。我知道在这九年的拍摄过程中我经历过一些事，我也知道珍娜你也有过，我们需要去找他们说：“嘿，我们得到了这个机会。我们能让它顺利进行吗？”他总是支持我们去实现它并想办法解决。
So how amazingly gracious that he made this window for you to go shoot that show. It's not like, oh, I'll have that opportunity later. This is important. And he knows that. It's important to get a pitch meeting. It's important to just sell a show. This isn't happening every day. We're all, you know, we're all mature.
所以他能为你腾出档期去拍那个节目，真的是太慷慨了。这可不是那种“哦，我以后还会有这个机会”的情况。这很重要。他很清楚这一点。拿到一个提案会议的机会很重要。成功卖出一个节目很重要。这种事可不是天天都有的。我们都，你知道的，我们都是成年人。
Am I younger than Angela and Jenna by 15, 20 years? Yes. But that's not the point. We're all mature people. We're all mature people. Oh. Well, you had pitched it and created it. It was your baby.
我比安吉拉和珍娜小15到20岁吗？是的。但这重点不在这。我们都是成年人。我们都是成年人。哦。好吧，毕竟那是你提案并创作的。那是你的心血结晶。
That's right. You got to go do it. And then you got to come back to the offices. You guys, if I had to choose, I don't know what I would have done because I burned in the hand. Yeah. So I would have had to say no to a show. I might have said no to a comedy. I probably would have said no to that.
没错。你必须去完成它。然后你还得回到办公室。伙计们，如果让我二选一，我真不知道自己会怎么做，因为鸟在林中不如手在手中。对。所以我可能不得不拒绝那个节目。我可能不得不拒绝一个喜剧节目。我当时很可能会拒绝的。
And that would have been horrible. Yeah. So I got to do both. I got to do both. You got to do both. And as Michael would say, it was a win, win, win. Very nicely done, Angela. Thank you so much. My pleasure. You're awesome. This was so nice. My pleasure. Love you, Angela. Love you, Jenna. Love you, Nice. My pleasure. Love you, Angela.
那可就太糟糕了。对。所以我两边都兼顾了。我两边都做到了。你两边都兼顾了。正如迈克尔所说，这是一个双赢、双赢、双赢的结局。干得漂亮，安吉拉。非常感谢。这是我的荣幸。你太棒了。这太美妙了。这是我的荣幸。爱你的，安吉拉。爱你的，珍娜。爱你的，纳斯。这是我的荣幸。爱你的，安吉拉。
Love you, Jenna. Love you, Oscar. Bye. Bye. All right. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Wasn't that amazing?
爱你的，珍娜。爱你的，奥斯卡。再见。再见。好吧。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。这难道不精彩吗？
He's hilarious. That was amazing. I love him so much. I love him so much. Now there's not that much more to talk about, but there are a couple little things before we wrap things up. I want to talk about Jim in the conference room. Fancy Stanford conference room.
他太搞笑了。太精彩了。我太爱他了。我太爱他了。现在没剩下多少内容要聊了，但在我们结束之前还有几个小事情。我想聊聊会议室里的吉姆。那个高大上的斯坦福会议室。
Yes. And he's conference room. Yes. And he's having his diversity training. And guys, Larry Wilmore. Larry Wilmore. Back again as Mr. Brown. Yes. Hero, acronym hero. It's all there.
是的。他在开多元化培训会议。伙计们，拉里·维尔摩。拉里·维尔摩。再次饰演布朗先生。是的。英雄，首字母缩写词：英雄。全都在那儿了。
You might notice that Jim has an empty chair next to him and he kind of looks wistfully at the chair. This is a nod to that moment in the previous diversity day where Pam fell asleep on his shoulder. It was kind of their first moment of connection, their first moment of physical connection. And he's remembering that. Yeah. They're both missing each other. They're missing each other.
你可能会注意到吉姆旁边有一个空椅子，他有些留恋地看着那把椅子。这是在向上一集《多元化日》中潘把头靠在他肩膀上睡着的那个时刻致敬。那是他们之间的第一个连接时刻，他们之间的第一次身体接触。他正在怀念那个时刻。是的。他们都在想念彼此。他们在想念彼此。
They are. And now back at Dunder Mifflin, Dwight gets a package. He gets a package from Jim. It's a gaydar detector. It looks like a little mini vacuum, but it's probably just a metal detector, right? It literally is a metal detector. I texted Phil Shea about it, and it is a repurposed metal detector, which makes total sense because it beeps when it goes across Oscar's belt. His belt. They all wore belts, guys. And so then, of course, it beeps when it goes across Dwight's belt.
确实如此。现在回到邓德·米夫林，德怀特收到了一个包裹。他收到了吉姆寄来的包裹。那是一个同性恋雷达探测器。它看起来像个小型的迷你吸尘器，但可能只是个金属探测器吧？它字面意思就是一个金属探测器。我为此给菲尔·谢伊发了短信，这确实是一个改装过的金属探测器，这完全说得通，因为它在扫过奥斯卡的皮带时会发出哔哔声。他的皮带。他们当时都系着皮带，伙计们。所以当然，当它扫过德怀特的皮带时也会发出哔哔声。
Oh, and then who has a little smile, a little wistful smile? Mm-hmm. Pam. That gem, she's thinking. She's thinking, aw, that Jim. He did a prank all the way from fancy Stanford. Yeah. Aw.
哦，然后谁露出了微笑，一个略带留恋的微笑？嗯——哼。潘。吉姆那家伙，她正在想。她在想，噢，吉姆。他大老远从高大上的斯坦福寄来一个恶作剧。是的。噢。
I know. And he doesn't know that I have an apartment now, and I'm eating frozen food because I canceled my wedding. And I'm going, I have art classes. I enrolled in art classes. I know. Like he said I should going I have art classes. I enrolled in art classes like he said I should. I know. I'm actually glad that Jim went to Stanford and that he doesn't know this about Pam, because I think it's really important that Pam has her own journey. Well, I think one of the reasons why Pam and Jim were able to get together in the end was because she had this time between relationships. Yes.
我知道。而他还不知道我现在有了公寓，而且因为我取消了婚礼，我一直在吃冷冻食品。我还去上课了。我报名了艺术课。我知道。就像他说过的那样去上课了。我报名了艺术课，就像他建议的那样。我知道。其实我很高兴吉姆去了斯坦福，而且他对潘的这些现状一无所知，因为我觉得潘有她自己的心路历程非常重要。好吧，我觉得潘和吉姆最终能走到一起的原因之一，就是因为她拥有了这段处在两段感情之间的空白期。是的。
She had this time alone. She's been with Roy for over a decade, I think, when we talk about it. Yeah. Maybe not that long, but since high school. Pam. I mean, they live together. She needs this alone time. I think it's good. It's good for them. We know it's all going to work out in the end. They don't know that yet, but this is the right thing. Kids, kids, take this time for yourself. Kids, don't go from one relationship to the next, okay? Figure out who you are. Have some time in between, okay? What are these accents we're doing?
她拥有了这段独处的时间。当我们算算看，她和罗伊在一起超过十年了，我想。是的。也许没有那么久，但从高中就开始了。潘。我的意思是，他们同居过。她需要这段独处的时间。我觉得这很好。对他们来说是件好事。我们知道最终一切都会皆大欢喜。他们现在还不知道这一点，但这是正确的选择。孩子们，孩子们，花点时间留给自己吧。孩子们，不要无缝衔接下一段感情，好吗？弄清楚你自己是谁。中间给自己留点时间，好吗？我们这是在学什么口音？
I don't know. Who are these women? I don't know. They're your bossy aunt. That's bossy aunt accent. All right, you guys, That was Gay Witch Hunt. Thanks so much for listening in. If we missed anything, write us because you know we like it.
我不知道。这些都是什么女人？我不知道。她们是那种爱指手画脚的阿姨。这就是爱指手画脚的阿姨口音。好吧，伙计们，以上就是《同性恋搜捕》这一集。非常感谢大家的收听。如果我们漏掉了什么，写信告诉我们，因为你知道我们喜欢这样。
You know we like it. We like it. And next week, we're going to talk about the convention. Yes. All right. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
你知道我们喜欢的。我们喜欢。下周我们将聊聊《大会》。好的。那我们下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitcherpremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音效工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问stitcherpremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。